Here we go. Ready? Three, two, one. Here we go. One and three. One, two and one. We're going live before we're going to go in seven, eight. Let it go. I'm going to the west coast into three. And five.
我们开始吧。准备好了吗？三、二、一。开始。一和三。一、二和一。我们在七、八之前就要直播了。放轻松。我要去西海岸，在三。还有五。
And four. Three. You saw it here first. World premiere. And four. And three. And three. Listen to me, I have to apologize for my coldness. Hey, did we do all the 3-2-1s? Yeah. Welcome to Smarlis!
还有四。三。你们在这里大饱眼福了。世界首映。还有四。还有三。还有三。听我说，我得为我的冷淡道歉。嘿，我们做完所有的3-2-1了吗？是的。欢迎来到Smarlis！
Smarlis! Smarlis! Smarlis! Blast! Oh my God, I'm so nervous. Okay, do we just go or do we practice once or... No, we're just gonna do it. We're just gonna do it. Okay, okay. Ready?
Smarlis！Smarlis！Smarlis！太棒了！天哪，我好紧张。好吧，我们是直接开始还是先彩排一次，或者……不，我们直接来。我们直接来。好吧，好吧。准备好了吗？
Hey, smartless listeners, this episode is brought to you in part by our friends at Verizon. If you're wishing for the new iPhone 15 Pro with Titanium, you don't need to find a genie in a bottle or I don't know, steal an unsuspecting kid's birthday wish. I get it, Sean, I get what you're doing there. If Verizon is making it easy to get Apple's latest and greatest with an amazing trade-in offer, even if your current iPhone has seen better days,
嘿，smartless听众们，本集部分内容由我们的朋友Verizon赞助播出。如果你一直在渴望拥有钛金属材质的全新iPhone 15 Pro，你不需要去神灯里找精灵，或者我不知道，去偷一个毫无防备的孩子生日愿望。我懂的，肖恩，我懂你在那儿干嘛。Verizon让购买苹果最新最棒的产品变得轻而易举，并提供超棒的以旧换新优惠，即使你目前的iPhone已经大不如前，
me, my phone is pristine, but you know, some of us just aren't as careful. No judgment here, though. Shot at you, Sean. That's I got it. And you got another one coming up, too. Yeah. Hey, look, Sean and I are well acquainted
我，我的手机完好无损，但你知道的，我们当中有些人就是没那么小心。不过这里不予评判。说你呢，肖恩。我懂的。而且你接下来还有一档节目呢。对。嘿，听着，肖恩和我对Verizon提供的优质服务和优惠非常熟悉，
with the excellent service and offerings from Verizon. So believe me when I say this upgrade deal is one for the books. Get the new iPhone 15 Pro with Titanium on Verizon. Plus Apple TV 4K and six months of Apple One Deal is one for the books. details, offer ends November 15th, 2023, and is only available in the United States. So, Will, you're back on American soil. Congratulations. Thank you.
所以相信我，当我说这次升级优惠绝对是史无前例的时候。在Verizon购买采用钛金属材质的全新iPhone 15 Pro。外加Apple TV 4K和六个月的Apple One，这次优惠绝对是史无前例。详情请见，优惠于2023年11月15日结束，仅限美国地区。那么，威尔，你回到美国本土了。恭喜。谢谢。
Yeah. Did you kiss the tarmac when you got off your plane? I did. I always do that. So you asked them, as soon as you get off the plane, you say, hey, can I just go down the little stairs here on the jetway? I just need to kiss the tarmac.
是啊。你下飞机的时候亲吻柏油跑道了吗？亲了。我总是这么做。所以你要求他们，一走出飞机，你就说，嘿，我能直接走廊桥这里的小楼梯下去吗？我只需要亲吻一下柏油跑道。
Well, yeah, I mean, it's the only way to get off this plane. It was get off the stairs under the jet. Oh, my God. Well, you're trying to do a private joke. It was, you definitely went commercial at least, right? I went from England. Of course I did. I had an incredible, as you guys saw,
好吧，是的，我是说，这是下飞机的唯一方式。那是走楼梯下到喷气式……哦，天哪。好吧，你在试图开一个私人玩笑。那绝对是坐民航客机回来的，对吧？我从英国回来的。我当然是。正如你们所看到的，我度过了一段不可思议的时光，
I say, that photo had an incredible time at Liverpool. Yeah, with the Yurgen. Sean, Will's doing really well, you know, he's, he's flying private occasionally. He's going, he's on, he's on the pitch in Liverpool. He's got a real, a real porny looking mustache on his face today. I'm, I'm gonna fresh new haircut. He's real boyish. Yeah, I went up to Liverpool. I watched them play at Ann Field, which is their ground. It was like such a dream come true for me. I know. Hang on. Sorry. And I got to my friend Tom took me up there kindly and that Werner Tom Werner and that's nice. Yeah. And Tom on the show. One of these. He's the best. So anyway, so Tom is part of obviously the group that they they on the red socks and
我说，那张照片在利物浦度过了不可思议的时光。是的，和于尔根在一起。肖恩，威尔现在过得真不错，你知道的，他偶尔坐私人飞机。他要去，他去过利物浦的球场。他今天脸上留着一撮看起来非常色情的小胡子。我，我换了个清爽的新发型。他看起来非常孩子气。是的，我去了利物浦。我看了他们在安菲尔德的比赛，那是他们的主场。对我和来说就像梦想成真一样。我知道。等一下。抱歉。我的朋友汤姆好心地带我去了那里，那是汤姆·沃纳，人很好。是的。汤姆也上过节目。其中之一。他最棒了。所以无论如何，汤姆显然是那个集团的一员，他们拥有红袜队和
they on Liverpool in the Pittsburgh, penguins. So feisty to say Tom is an old friend. Jason, you know, I've played golf them a number of times. He's a great dude. And he invited me up to the game. I went up there. It was incredible. Billy, hold the end of when they got a big win against West Ham.
他们拥有利物浦和匹兹堡企鹅队。说汤姆是个老朋友真是太热情了。杰森，你知道的，我和他打过好几次高尔夫球。他是个很棒的家伙。他邀请我去现场看球。我去了。那真是太棒了。比利，记住最后他们在对阵西汉姆联的比赛中取得了大胜。
So it was all that's fine. Yeah, really cool. I was like, man got a win. They got a big win against West Ham. Oh, they did. That's fine. Yeah, really cool. I was like, man, I'm want to know. I said to your conclop, I go, I want to know. So I'm kind of good luck in, I guess you have to add me back. His his his assistant coach, who's like, so number one right hand guy, this guy, Pep Lenders, who's a Dutch football coach. He's a massive smartless fan. So Pep, I know you're listening. I think he's got a huge fan. He's got a huge fan.
所以一切都很好。是的，真的很酷。我当时想，天哪，赢了一场。他们在对阵西汉姆联的比赛中取得了大胜。哦，他们赢了。那太好了。是的，真的很酷。我当时想，天哪，我想赢。我对尤尔根·克洛普说，我想要赢。所以我算是个幸运符吧，我想你得让我回归。他的，他的助理教练，也就是头号得力助手，这个叫佩普·林德斯的人，是个荷兰足球教练。他是个超级smartless粉丝。所以佩普，我知道你在听。我觉得他是个超级粉丝。他是个超级粉丝。
Scotty has a CPAP. And Billy, Billy Hogan, who runs the team day to day, he's also a massive, massive smartless fan, listens to every episode. Really? Yeah. Every episode. So it was kind of like, it felt very good. They were all happy to. Well,
斯科蒂有一个CPAP呼吸机。而负责球队日常运营的比利·霍根，也是一个超级无敌的smartless粉丝，每一集都听。真的吗？是的。每一集都听。所以感觉真的很棒。他们都很高兴。好吧，
now because let me because like I know I know what a what a what a little you know, boy you are in the best sense the world when it word when it comes to liverpool or so you're you're trying to get one. And if I've said to people in the past, the only good thing about being semi-recognizable is that you can get a good table at a restaurant that's hard to book. But most importantly, when you meet your heroes, there's a decent chance they might know who you are and you can skip all the sort of fan,
现在因为让我——因为就像我知道——我知道你是一个多么——在利物浦这方面，用最好的词来形容，你是一个多么可爱的小男孩。所以你正试图得到一张。如果我过去对人们说过，半有名气的唯一好处就是你可以在一家很难预订的餐厅里订到一张好桌子。但最重要的是，当你见到你的偶像时，有很大的几率他们可能知道你是谁，你可以省去所有那种粉丝式的……
like, oh, I'm so sorry, do you mind if I ask you? I said, they wanna talk to you too. So, yeah, would'm so sorry. Do you mind if I ask you? I said, they want to talk to you too. So yeah, was that amazing for you? It was amazing. Wasn't I don't know if it's because Pep had told you're going to or you're going to actually knew, but you're in club who I totally admire. I he comes towards me smiling. And I of course, I do it to everybody.
比如，哦，非常抱歉，你介意我问你吗？我说，他们也想跟你谈谈。所以，是的，是非常抱歉，你介意我问你吗？我说，他们也想跟你谈谈。所以，是的，这对你来说太神奇了吗？太神奇了。我不知道是不是因为佩普告诉你了，或者你真的知道了，但你在克洛普面前，我完全崇拜他。他微笑着向我走来。我当然对所有人都这样做。
I do it to my agent. I go, hey, you're going to will will our net and he goes, I know who you are. And he came and give me a huge hug. It was chap, he's with me. Chap is like, what is happening? I know. This is, this is so freaking crazy. That's so cool.
我对我的经纪人都这样。我说，嘿，你要去——威尔，我们的网——他说，我知道你是谁。他走过来给了我一个大大的拥抱。当时查普和我在一起。查普的表情就像是：这到底是怎么回事？我知道。这，这简直太疯狂了。太酷了。
Sean, we got a chap you mentioned. Yeah, we got a chap. And we did, but we're, you know, smartless. We are the official podcast of, of, of Liverpool football club. Yeah, that's so exciting. I got a flat tire yesterday. Should we get to the guest? Yeah.
肖恩，我们有个叫查普的人，你刚才提到了。是的，我们有个查普。我们确实有，但是你知道的，smartless。我们是利物浦足球俱乐部的官方播客。耶，太令人兴奋了。我昨天车胎爆了。我们要聊嘉宾了吗？对。
No, by the way, here's the exciting. I got a flat tire yesterday. Should we get to the guest? Yeah. No. Yeah. Shots. By the way, here's the other thing I was going to say. So I come back state side as we say. Good. Those others more. Shuns juggling his bosoms. Bisms.
不，顺便说一句，这里有激动人心的事。我昨天车胎爆了。我们要聊嘉宾了吗？对。不。对。肖恩。顺便说一句，我要说的另一件事是：我回到美国本土了，正如我们所说的那样。太好了。还有更多。肖恩正在拍着他的胸部。胸肌。
I come back and I start watching football and American football. Yeah. I see you two clowns every 10 minutes in your. Sorry about that. Yeah. I see you two clowns every 10 minutes in your, sorry about that. Yeah. In your Verizon spot. Yeah. You guys, I love you guys both. And you're in there and you're hilarious. And you guys have obviously great Kim and the great Will Speck and Josh Gordon directed it. Yeah. Yeah. And it made me so happy. I'm just to see you guys. No. The problem is that, you know, they, they, they came to us because the iPhone in Verizon is a fan of, of smartness. So they thought to come to us because the iPhone in Verizon is a fan of smartness. So they thought to come to us,
我回来后开始看橄榄球，美式橄榄球。是的。我每隔10分钟就能看到你们两个小丑在你们的——抱歉。是的。我每隔10分钟就能看到你们两个小丑在你们的——抱歉。是的。在你们的Verizon广告里。是的。你们两个，我爱死你们两个了。你们在里面，太搞笑了。而且你们显然有着很棒的化学反应，由伟大的威尔·斯佩克和乔希·戈登执导。对。对。这让我太开心了。我很高兴看到你们。不。问题是，你知道，他们，他们，他们来找我们是因为iPhone和Verizon是smartless的粉丝。所以他们想到来找我们，因为iPhone和Verizon是smartless的粉丝。所以他们想到来找我们，
the reason listener that will is not on that is because he's got a prior commitment with a phone company. Yes, I have Jason, you're right. I have a prior commitment with a phone company, but what was fun was- There's more money for me and Sean, basically. Yeah, coming home, coming
听众朋友们，威尔之所以没能参与，是因为他之前已经和一家电话公司有约在先了。是的，我有，杰森，你说的对。我之前确实和一家电话公司有约在先，但有趣的是——这给我和肖恩带来了更多钱，基本上就是这样。是的，回到家里，回到
back and seeing you guys on the air. It was like, I'd been gone and then like, and because it was Monday night football, I was like, look at these guys. Look at these. It was very good. You're not very good that whole day, Sean. Well, likewise. Now, wait, was that the first, Sean, it's the first time you and I have acted together,
国内看到你们在电视上播出。这感觉就像我离开了一段时间，然后因为那天是周一橄榄球之夜（Monday Night Football），我就想：看看这俩家伙。看看这俩。那整天表现得都不太好，肖恩。嗯，彼此彼此。等等，那是——肖恩，那是我俩第一次一起演戏，
right? I think so, yeah. I think it was. Yeah, I did the doc and everything, but that was just us playing. I guess we were playing ourselves in this spot too, but yeah. Anyway, it was fun. It was a real dream. Good God. You made me laugh. Are you both, for sure, you both look and Jason, I want to say that you didn't look great. You look great. You did not look puffy. Really? Yeah. You look very strong. I think I mean, should a little bit of help in post-production. I look like a good man.
对吧？我想是的，是的。我想是的。是的，我拍过纪录片之类的，但那只是我们自己在玩。我想我们在广告里也是扮演我们自己，但不管怎样。总之这很有趣。这简直是个梦想。天哪。你们逗笑我了。你们俩，肯定的，你们俩看起来——杰森，我想说你看起来状态不错。你看起来很棒。你看起来没有浮肿。真的吗？是的。你看起来很强壮。我想，我是说，后期制作稍微帮了一点忙。我看起来像个好人。
It's just a little bit. Just a little under the eyes. I think a little post-production. It's called tough production. Yeah, tough production. But I don't know. Listen, you know, you got to be pretty on TV. Yeah. Sure.
只是稍微一点。眼睛下面稍微处理了一下。我想稍微做了一下后期制作。这叫精细制作。对，精细制作。但不管怎样。听着，你知道的，在电视上你得长得好看。对。当然。
You guys. Yeah. Let's get to our guest. Okay. This person's got stuff to do. Today's guest is a Grammy winner. What? Just bring him on. She has a degree from Stanford.
你们俩。对。让我们欢迎我们的嘉宾吧。好吧。这位可是大忙人。今天的嘉宾是一位格莱美奖得主。什么？赶紧把她请出来。她拥有斯坦福大学学位。
She's a gifted fisherman. She's got part Dutch, Canadian, English, Irish, Russian, she plays volleyball, basketball. She also has multiple Emmys. She's a Rhodes scholar and earned a doctor, philosophy, and politics from Oxford. What's that? She's written four books, had a crossword puzzle in New York Times, had her own radio show,
她是一位极具天赋的渔夫。她有部分荷兰、加拿大、英语、爱尔兰、俄罗斯血统，她打排球、篮球。她还获得过多次艾美奖。她是罗德学者，并获得了牛津大学的哲学和政治学博士学位。什么？她写过四本书，在《纽约时报》上有过自己的填字游戏，拥有自己的广播节目，
a couple of podcasts in her own TV show. What's happening? She's a hero to summon inconvenient to others. Please welcome Robert and Elaine's daughter, David's sister, Susan's partner, and one of my personal heroes, America's own Rachel and Maddo. Oh my God. Yeah. Now, America's own Rachel and Maddo. Oh my God. Yeah. Now that's a booking.
几个播客以及她自己的电视节目。这是什么情况？她是某些人的英雄，另一些人的眼中钉。请欢迎罗伯特和伊莱恩的女儿，大卫的姐姐，苏珊的伴侣，以及我个人的英雄之一，全美当之无愧的Rachel Maddow。哦，天哪。是的。现在，全美当之无愧的Rachel Maddow。哦，天哪。好吧，这阵容绝了。
That's a booking. That is like a cry. I'm going to cry. Cry on me. This is crazy. This is a top notch booking, baby. I know. How did you get to me by saying you got to be pretty to be on TV?
这阵容绝了。这简直就像是一声——我要哭了。为我哭吧。这太疯狂了。这绝对是顶级嘉宾阵容，宝贝。我知道。你是怎么通过说“上电视必须长得好看”这句话来过渡到介绍我的？
Okay, let's go. The get that was that was cruel. This is very. Rachel, I've go the guest. I thought that was cruel. That was just so cruel. Rachel, I've been mistaken for you so many times. You should check in in the morning about who's using the haircut today. That should be noted until he talks. I'll definitely got the reminds me,
好吧，我们开始吧。那句话——那太残忍了。这太——雷切尔，我嘉宾。我觉得那太残忍了。那实在是太残忍了。雷切尔，我好几次被误认成你。你早上应该核对一下今天是谁在用这个发型。这必须得记下来，直到他开口。我绝对有——这让我想起，
I'll never forget Will, Amy cracked me up one day. She said, what didn't she call herself? How did she make some cut? She said, I am, I'm the female Chris Matthews. Who said that? A.B. polar. Did she really? She called herself that once.
我永远不会忘记威尔，有一次艾美把我逗乐了。她说，她自己叫什么来着？她是怎么自嘲的？她说，我是，我是女版克里斯·马修斯（Chris Matthews）。谁说的？艾米·波勒（Amy Poehler）。真的吗？她曾经这么称呼过自己。
I thought it was a photo station. I actually, that's kind of a good party game, which MSNBC host are you? That is not bad. I saw you, Rachel. I saw you walking down the street in New York one time, like a couple years ago. And I was like, I'm a pure start to your story. Keep going. I was, I was following closely behind you in a van.
我觉得这挺有意思的。其实，这算是一个不错的派对游戏：你是哪个MSNBC的主持人？这还真不赖。我见过你，雷切尔。好几年前，我在纽约街头看到你走路来着。我当时就想，我是你故事里的纯粹开端。继续说。我当时，我当时开着一辆面包车紧随其后。
I'm not exactly a peer-to-peer. I could smell you, is you, huh? And I was like, hey, right, screw it. I was like, no, no, I can't. I'm too nervous. I was too nervous. Was I doing something weird?
我可不算是平起平坐。我能闻到你的气味，是你吧，哈？我当时想，嘿，雷切尔，算了吧。我当时想，不，不，我不能。我太紧张了。我当时太紧张了。我当时在做什奇怪的举动吗？
Or was I just walking? No, you're just walking. You're just walking. Rachel, I am so, so excited that you're here. You, I will, with all respect to all of the guests that have been nice enough to say yes to my invites. I will say you're one and one A with, with radio head for me. Oh, well, Sean, can you attest to that? Yes. Jason talks about you all the time. I mean, all I do is watch MSN. It's true.
还是我只是在走路？不，你只是在走路。你只是在走路。雷切尔，你来到这里，我真的，真的太兴奋了。你——我，对于所有好心答应我邀请的嘉宾，我都表示敬意。我要说，对于我来说，你和电台司令（Radio Head）并列第一。哦，好吧，肖恩，你能作证吗？是的。杰森整天都在谈论你。我是说，我做的一切就是看MSN。真的。
It's true. It's 12 hours a day. It's true. Do you think you are Joy Reid if you had to be one of us? There isn't anyone I don't love on that. It's anyway. I think if I am any other host, I'm, I think I'm Chris Hayes. I am Chris Hayes hangs a son for me.
真的。一天12个小时。真的。如果你必须在我们当中选一个，你觉得你会是乔伊·里德（Joy Reid）吗？这里面没有一个是我不喜欢的。总之。我想如果我要当别的什么主持人，我，我想我会是克里斯·海耶斯（Chris Hayes）。克里斯·海耶斯对我来说就像是太阳。
I can't see that. You guys seem, I've seen you guys, I've seen you guys sort of go back and forth a little bit over the years and you seem like you guys legitimately get along very well. You see eye to eye. Yeah.
我可看不出来。你们俩看起来——我见过你们俩——这些年来，我见过你们俩有过一些互动，你们看起来彼此相处得非常融洽。你们心有灵犀。是的。
Very collegial workplace here. People like each other. But now we no longer have the handoff. The A, A, you're only one day a week and that one day a week, you're leading now is Jan Saki. Another past guest party. I love to. So guest with you guys. Oh, good. She's awesome. Now, do you think she's going to be
这里的工作氛围非常同事化。大家都很喜欢彼此。不过现在我们不再有交接了。A，A，你一周只上一天班，而那一天的接班人现在是珍·普萨基（Jen Psaki）。又一位过去的嘉宾。我太喜欢了。所以和你们一起做嘉宾。哦，太好了。她太棒了。现在，你觉得她会像
as good as at the on time handoff as Chris was? He was never late. He was so good about cutting off guests and getting to you on time. So humbling because he made such an effort to always make sure at 9,000,000, I was ready to go. Whereas I'm always traipsing like a minute and a half into Lawrence's show. Oh, you do 10 minutes with Lawrence on his because he makes sure he's got to tell everybody who he's got while he's still got your audience.
克里斯那样准时交接吗？他从来没有迟到过。他在切断嘉宾发言和按时把节目交给你这方面做得太棒了。这太让人谦卑了，因为他总是付出努力确保在9点整我已经准备好上台了。而我总是拖拖拉拉地在劳伦斯（Lawrence）的节目开始一分半钟后才晃悠过去。哦，你在劳伦斯的节目上做10分钟，因为他确保在还拥有你的观众时，他得告诉所有人他请到了谁。
Which I get, I would do the same thing. Wait, I got a question, Rachel. When you, it's to the kind of to that point, when you're, what's fascinating to me about what you do is how you fill in the gaps and you constantly have something to talk about endlessly. Like, like, how much of that is like on a prompter or on a car or on a card or you just like, you've done, how much research before every single show? Are you just filled with education in your brain where you can just keep talking
我懂的，我也会这么做。等等，我有个问题，雷切尔。当你在——说到这一点，对我来说，关于你的工作最吸引人的地方在于你是如何填补空白的，而且你总是有说不完的话题，滔滔不绝。比如，这其中有多少是通过提词器、提示卡，或者你只是——你做过，每期节目开始前要做多少研究？你的大脑里是不是塞满了各种知识，所以你可以一直滔滔不绝地
about? I'm weighing in it like we do. I don't have any other life, for example. I don't have like things. It's just this. So anything where it's like me talking to the camera, I have written it down. If it's me interacting with another human, I have not written it down. So that's the way to know if it's in the teleprompter.
谈论这些？就像我们一样，我全神贯注。我没有别的生活，比如说。我没有别的事情。只有这个。所以任何对着镜头说话的内容，我都写下来了。如果是我和另一个人互动，我没有写下来。所以这就是分辨它是不是在提词器上的方法。
But like for instance, your interview with Cassidy Hutchitz in the other day was incredible. You were certainly prepared for that. You had questions that were very specific that we all really wanted to hear the answers on and she was incredible and beautiful forthcoming. I mean, book interviews are great, but it's got, I mean, I'm only interested in talking
但是比如，你前几天对卡西迪·哈钦森（Cassidy Hutchinson）的采访简直不可思议。你绝对是为此做过准备的。你提出了非常具体的问题，而这些正是我们所有人都非常渴望听到答案的，而且她表现得非常不可思议、坦率而大方。我是说，图书采访是很棒的，但它必须——我是说，只有当我真的对某本书感兴趣时，我才有兴趣跟别人聊这本书。所以我是读过这本书的。而且，一旦你读过这本书，你就不需要做太多其他的准备了，只要你掌控全局并且能理解发生了什么。雷切尔，给这几个家伙解释一下什么是书。对，那是什么意思？他们俩从来不读任何书。整整一本书只为了做一个采访。这太让人震惊了。
to people about a book if I'm interested in the book. And so I've always read the book. And so, but once you've read the book, you don't have to do that much other preparation as long as you rock it and you can't understand what's going on. Rachel, like, explain to the guys what a book is. Yeah, what's that mean? Neither of them reads ever. It's an entire book for one interview. It's alarming.
向人们谈论一本书，如果我对这本书感兴趣的话。所以我总是读这本书。而且，一旦你读了这本书，你就不需要做太多其他的准备，只要你表现出色并且能理解发生了什么。瑞秋，向大家解释一下什么是书。是的，那是什么意思？他们两个从不读书。一次采访竟然要读整整一本书。这太令人担忧了。
It's just stunning. I know that. You know how stuff gets stapled together? You move the staple to the long side of the paper. Still long side of the paper and it's left to right top to bottom Right in TV terms just put it in like a television program Imagine a television program but all the dialogue was how else would I crunch into? Q cards you can hold you know what yeah, but what I was saying is just the the ability to like when if something goes wrong Or the satellite didn't connect sorry sorry, we can't get them.
简直太惊人了。我知道这个。你知道东西是怎么装订在一起的吗？你把钉书钉移到纸张的长边上。依然是纸张的长边，从左到右，从上到下。用电视术语来说，直接把它放进类似电视节目的东西里。想象一下一个电视节目，但所有的对话都是——不然我怎么能把它压缩成Q卡？你可以拿着，你知道的，对。不过我想说的是，那种能力——当有什么地方出错，或者卫星连不上时，抱歉，抱歉，我们连不上他们。
And you just fill the space right away. Well, by the way, I will say, Rachel, just so you don't have to be too embarrassed about why you are so smart. I will say that part of the thing is that because I imagine someone like Rachel is so well-read that she's able to talk on many different subjects at all times, because she has points of reference other than, you know, the Golden Bachelor, you guys. So, which is a bear waiting for the watching match. I know neither can I, by the way, neither can I have never watched any of the bachelor's. No, never. And I want to watch that one too. What does it take to be Golden? How old is he?
然后你立刻就能填补这段空白。好吧，顺便说一句，我要说的是，雷切尔，为了不让你对“为什么你这么聪明”感到太尴尬。我要说的是，部分原因在于——因为我想像雷切尔这样的人博览群书，所以她能够随时就许多不同的主题发言，因为她有除了你们看的《黄金单身汉》（Golden Bachelor）之外的参考点。所以，天哪，我迫不及待地想看那个节目。我知道我也一样，顺便说一句，我也一样，从来没看过任何《单身汉》。不，从来没有。我也想看那个。要成为“黄金”需要具备什么条件？他多大了？
Over 50. He's 72. You know, they had the Golden Bachelor once in Germany, but that was different. It was a different show. Here, get rid of the joke. So, here we go. Nope. It is what you think it is. Great. I've been there.
过50岁了。他72岁。你知道的，他们在德国办过一次《黄金单身汉》，但那是另一回事。那是另一个节目。好了，别开玩笑了。所以，我们开始吧。不。它就是你想的那样。太棒了。我经历过。
Sure. No, but Rachel, you have said, and when I say that, I'm talking about my research on Wikipedia, that you think you have an obligation to, since you have a light on the camera, that you need to have something to say when that light comes on. And you're very responsible in making sure that you're prepared
当然。不，不过雷切尔，你曾经说过——当我这么说时，我是指我在维基百科上做的研究——你认为你有义务，既然摄像机前有盏灯亮着，那么当这盏灯亮起时，你需要有话可说。而且你在确保自己做好准备方面非常有责任感，
and you're brilliant at doing that A-block where you are giving us some story. We have no idea what the hell you're talking about for a few minutes in the best way. And then you land the plane and contextualize what this story, we have no idea what the hell you're talking about for a few minutes in the best way. And then you land the plane and contextualize what this story and history was as it pertains to something that's going on today. And it's just thank you for that. You hold me hand every night or once a week now.
并且你在做A段（A-block）时表现得极其出色，在那里你会给我们讲一个故事。在前几分钟里，我们根本不知道你在胡说八道些什么，但这恰恰是最妙的地方。然后你平稳着陆，将这个我们一开始完全不知所云的故事和历史置于当下的语境中，看它如何与今天发生的事情相关联。谢谢你带给我们这一切。你每天晚上或现在每周一次地牵着我的手。
It's, you know, that's the way that I learn. If something's going on that I think is interesting or important, I wanna be able to say why it's interesting or why it's important. And usually that involves some sort of origin story or some sort of historical analog or something like that. And so that's usually where those stories come from. But when it comes to just having something to say, it's just I really firmly believe in reading widely,
你知道，那是我学习的方式。如果有什么事情正在发生，而我觉得它很有趣或很重要，我就想能够说出它为什么有趣或为什么重要。通常这会涉及到某种起源故事、某种历史类比之类的事情。所以这些故事通常就是这么来的。但当谈到只是有话可说时，我只是坚信要广泛阅读，
not only reading about the thing you're supposedly researching, but just reading a lot. Yeah, I think, you know, Rich, tell me if you, if this rings true for you at all, if something like you, you went to Stanford, your Rhodes Scholar, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're really well educated, you, obviously,
不仅要阅读你假设正在研究的东西，还要读很多书。是的，我想，你知道，雷切尔，告诉我这是否符合你的真实情况：如果你去过斯坦福，你是罗德学者，你，你，你，你受过极好的教育，你，显然，
it can, you know, speak to a number of different, you know, sort of big issues. There used to be a time when somebody like you came along and was so well informed and was so smart, and able to, you know, really deal with a lot of complex issues at one time and blah, blah, blah. They would maybe turn all their talents to the public sector.
可以，你知道的，对许多不同的，你知道的，重大问题发表高见。过去曾有过这样一段时期，当像你这样的人出现时，博学多才，聪明过人，能够，你知道的，真正同时处理许多复杂的问题，等等等等。他们也许会把自己的所有才华都投向公共部门。
They would try in a way to, you know, to serve, you know, in government, et cetera, et cetera. And now, partially, and it's just really a result of where we are as a society, the highest calling almost is entertainment and celebrity. But also, but within that, you get to kind of have your cake and eat it too, because you get to go do that.
他们会试图以某种方式，你知道的，在政府等部门服务。而现在，部分原因，这其实也是我们作为社会的现状所导致的，最高的追求几乎成了娱乐和名人效应。但同时，在这个过程中，你既可以鱼与熊掌兼得，因为你可以去从事那个行业。
But in a way, you get to serve the public by, as Jason said, helping people understand what's going on. You kind of get to do both. Do you see it in that way that you're, that you're, and again, I don't want you to, you know, say that you're doing some great thing for the greater good in that, you know, but you kind of are, of course. It's nice of you to think of it that way.
但在某种程度上，正如杰森所说，通过帮助人们了解正在发生的事情，你也在为公众服务。你某种程度上两边都兼顾了。你是否认为你是在这样做的，而且——再次重申，我不是要让你（你知道的）说你是在为更广泛的利益做多伟大的事情（你知道的），但你其实确实在某种程度上是这样的。你这么想真是太好了。
I mean, I, I definitely feel like my job is trying to understand things myself so that I can explain them for lots of people. And so that is a very satisfying job, particularly at a time when things, I think the news, feels overwhelming or devastating to lots of people. To have it be your job, the thing you get paid to do, to try to understand it and explain it in a way that makes sense, that's real. That's a very therapeutic thing. But in terms of what I'm trying to do in the world,
我是说，我绝对觉得我的工作是努力自己去理解事物，以便我能为许多人解释它们。所以这是一份非常令人满意的的工作，特别是在这样一个时期——我认为新闻对许多人来说让人感到压倒性或具有毁灭性。把这作为你的工作，作为你拿报酬去做的事，去努力理解它并以一种能够说得通的、真实的方式解释它，这是一件非常有疗愈作用的事情。但就我试图在这个世界上做的事情而言，
I was an activist before I got involved in the media and I definitely see a real hard dividing line between those two things. I spent a long time trying to get people to do things, trying to get policies to change, trying to advocate for specific people in trouble or whatever it was. And I stopped doing advocacy and started explaining. There's no money.
我在涉足媒体之前是一名活动家，我绝对能在这两者之间划一条非常清晰的分界线。我花了很长时间试图让人们去做事情，试图改变政策，试图为陷入困境的特定人群等等进行倡导。然后我停止了倡导，开始了解释。这里面没有钱。
There's no money in the table of restaurant. Well, as Jason said, but I get it. But talk more about that Rachel because that's a, that's, was it, I would imagine it was, it would be difficult to turn that switch off of advocacy with the end game being actual change and results, whereas now you're, you're probably able to say much more, which with much more specificity, deeper reach, much more research, but you need to be a little more, I guess, indifferent to whether the results are going to come because you're presenting information and potentially hoping that people react to it and change their patterns from it.
餐厅的桌子上没有钱。好吧，正如杰森所说，但我懂。但多聊聊这个吧，雷切尔，因为这是一个——这曾是——我想象要关掉“倡导”这个开关会很困难，因为终极目标是实际的改变和成果，而现在你，你可能能够说得更多，准确度更高，覆盖面更深，研究也更深入，但你可能需要对结果是否会到来表现得更无所谓一些，因为你只是在提供信息，并潜在地希望人们对它做出反应并从中改变他们的模式。
But there's no follow-up to that. Like there is in the other work you were doing perhaps. Yeah, it's interesting. I really feel like what I'm doing now has a bigger impact, but I have to have less ego about what it is. Because I'm not trying to change one pilot. I used to work for the ACLU National Prison Project, and I was in ASEAN ADAP ASEAN, in ASEAN,
但这之后没有后续行动。就像你在做其他工作时可能会有的那样。是的，这很有趣。我真的觉得我现在做的事情影响更大，但我必须对它是什么少一点自我（ego）。因为我不是试图去改变某一个——我过去曾在美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）国家监狱项目工作，而且我曾是一个东盟（ASEAN）——我在东盟（ASEAN）——
in ASEAN activist sort of, hey, day. And we were always trying to get a thing done. And I feel like I know how to do that and I was pretty good at it, but I was sort of average good at it. There was a lot of other people doing it that were better than me. But with what I'm doing now,
在东盟（ASEAN）活动家的鼎盛时期。我们总是试图把事情做好。我觉得我知道该怎么做，而且我做得相当不错，但我只是中等水平的好。有很多人比我做得更好。但对于我现在正在做的事情，
I feel like hopefully by creating more understanding, by making what's important about the news and current events really plain to people, it makes it possible for people to make their own decisions about either just participating or doing activism. Yeah. We'll be right back. Smartless is sponsored by ADT.
我觉得希望通过创造更多的理解，通过向人们真正阐明新闻和时事的重要之处，它让人们能够就参与或开展激进主义做出他们自己的决定。我们马上回来。Smartless由ADT赞助播出。
Now ADT professionally installs Google Nest products, so your home is safe and smart. Much smarter than I am. The only way is up. You can check in on your home and manage your security system from virtually anywhere. With Nest Cams and the Nest Doorbell, you can even get intelligent alerts
现在ADT专业安装谷歌Nest产品，让您的家既安全又智能。比我聪明多了。生活节节高升。你可以从几乎任何地方查看你的家并管理你的安全系统。有了Nest摄像头和Nest门铃，你甚至可以获得智能警报，
so you receive notifications on what matters most. Google Nest Cams can tell the difference between a person, an animal, a vehicle, or with the Nestorbell, even a package. And with Nest Aware as part of your monthly ADT service, you get 30 days of event video history and even smarter notifications like when a familiar or unfamiliar face is seen. Plus, when every second counts,
这样你就能收到关于最重要事情的通知。谷歌Nest摄像头可以区分人、动物、车辆，或者通过Nest门铃，甚至能认出包裹。作为你每月ADT服务一部分的Nest Aware，能为你提供30天的事件视频历史记录，甚至还有更智能的通知，比如当看到熟悉或陌生的面孔时。另外，当每一秒都至关重要时，
you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring. You can view video of an alarm event and verify or cancel an alarm with just a tap. When the most trusted name and home security adds the intelligence of Google, you've got a home with no worries. Go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-ASAP. Google Nest Cam, Nest Doorbell, and Nest aware
你可以信赖ADT全天候24/7的专业监控。你可以查看警报事件的视频，只需轻轻一按即可确认或取消警报。当家居安全中最值得信赖的名字加入谷歌的智能技术时，你就拥有了一个高枕无忧的家。今天就访问ADT.com或致电1-800-ADT-ASAP。Google Nest Cam、Nest Doorbell和Nest Aware
are trademarks of Google LLC. Smartless is sponsored by Better Help. So in my life, I'll start talking to Scotty about something and I'll start the conversation in the middle of a sentence because in my brain, I've already said the other half like the top half and he's like, wait, I don't even know what you're talking about. Who are you talking about?
是Google LLC的商标。Smartless由BetterHelp赞助。所以在我生活中，我会开始跟斯科蒂谈论某事，而且我会从一句话的中间开始对话，因为在我的大脑里，我已经说完了前半部分，比如上半部分，而他就会说，等等，我甚至不知道你在说什么。你在跟谁说话？
You need to catch me up. So a lot of the times I get ahead of myself instead of stopping being present and catching him up on things because my mind races so fast, right? So do you ever feel like your brain is kind of getting in its own way? Like you know what you should do, what's good for you, but you just don't do it. Therapy helps you figure out what's holding you back. So you can work for yourself instead of against yourself. If you're thinking of starting therapy,
你需要赶上我的节奏。所以很多时候我总是跑在自己的前面，而不是停下来保持当下并把事情的来龙去脉告诉他，因为我的思维转得太快了，对吧？所以你有没有觉得你的大脑有时在阻碍它自己？就像你知道你应该做什么，什么对你有益，但你就是不做。疗愈能帮你找出是什么在阻碍你。这样你就能为自己工作，而不是与自己作对。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，
give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Every single time I talk to my therapist, especially about being present,
不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在线上，旨在提供便利、灵活，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与有执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。每次我跟我的治疗师谈话时，尤其是关于保持当下的谈话，
it always makes me feel better, instead of falling back into the rapid fire brain overload. Make your brain, your friend, with better help. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month that's betterhelp.htlp.com slash smartlis. Smartlis is brought to you in part by Amazon Prime.
总是让我感觉更好，而不是重新陷入那种狂风暴雨般的大脑超载状态。让你的大脑成为你的朋友，就用BetterHelp。今天就访问betterhelp.com斜杠smartlis，首月即可享受九折优惠，网址是betterhelp.com/smartlis。Smartless由亚马逊Prime部分赞助播出。
Amazon Prime offers a range of services like Prime Video, Amazon Prime Music, and Prime Fast Free Shipping. It's this collection that helps you pursue your passions and get more out of whatever you're into or getting into. Prime helps you get more out of your interests. Maybe you're a jazz fan and you want to watch a jazz-centric movie on Prime Video, or listen to some smooth jazz on Amazon Prime music. And while listening to a jazz playlist, you might be inspired to buy a book about the legendary
Amazon Prime提供了一系列服务，如Prime视频、Amazon Prime音乐和Prime快速免费送货。正是这种组合帮助你追求热爱，并从你的任何兴趣或正在涉足的事物中获得更多收获。Prime能帮你从兴趣中获得更多。也许你是个爵士乐迷，想在Prime视频上观看一部以爵士乐为核心的电影，或者在Amazon Prime音乐上听一些流畅的爵士乐。在听爵士乐播放列表的同时，你可能会受到启发，去买一本关于传奇人物
Miles Davis. There are so many scenarios where Prime could make life a little richer that for me to list all of them would be impossible from shopping, to streaming, to saving, it's on prime. Visit amazon.com slash prime to get more out of whatever you're into. And now back to the show. So Rachel, your latest book, prequel, is a bit of a cautionary tale yet that yes, that is applicable to what we're talking about right here, that in fact America went through this at least once before, right around World War II, is this story that you've uncovered correct?
迈尔斯·戴维斯（Miles Davis）的书。有太多这样的场景，Prime能让生活变得更丰富多彩，如果要我把它们全部列举出来是不可能的，从购物、流媒体到省钱，Prime应有尽有。访问amazon.com/prime，从你的任何兴趣中获得更多收获。现在回到节目中来。那么雷切尔，你的最新力作《前传》（Prequel）有点像是一个警世故事，是的，这确实适用于我们在这里讨论的内容，事实上美国至少经历过一次这样的事情，就在二战前后，你揭露的这个故事是真的吗？
Yeah, I mean, it's basically, I think it's a positive story because there was all these Americans who fought against it, but there was this really big fight in the lead up to World War II in this country against the fascist movement in this country that in a lot of cases was actually working with Nazi Germany to try to set up a similar form of government here. And we had paramilitary groups,
对，我的意思是，基本上，我认为这是一个积极的故事，因为有所有这些美国人在与它抗争，但在二战前的这个国家，发生了一场非常大的斗争，反对这个国家的法西斯运动，在很多情况下，该运动实际上正与纳粹德国合作，试图在这里建立一种类似的政府形态。我们有准军事组织，
and we had a Nazi agent working with lots of members of Congress on a big property. And it was seemingly a very big movement that had quite a bit of support. You know, there's lots of documentation to that. Yeah. The, you know, the most famous industrialist in the country, Henry Ford, was part of it. The biggest national hero at the time, Charles Lindbergh, was a big part of it. I'm watching the documentary. He just started watching it last night. It's called the United States and the Holocaust. Oh, yeah, the Ken Burns, yeah. Yes, it's fascinating.
我们有纳粹特工在很多财产问题上与许多国会议员合作。这似乎是一个规模非常大、拥有相当多支持的运动。你知道，有很多文件可以证明这一点。是的，你知道，这个国家最著名的实业家亨利·福特（Henry Ford）是其中的一部分。当时最大的民族英雄查尔斯·林德伯格（Charles Lindbergh）是其中的很大一部分。我正在看那部纪录片。我昨晚刚开始看。它叫《美国与大屠杀》（The United States and the Holocaust）。哦，是的，肯·伯恩斯（Ken Burns）的那部，是的。是的，太迷人了。
It's just a little more like that. And he has a lot on Charles Coglin and Lindbergh. Yes. So Coglin was the biggest media figure we've ever had in America. And he was a self-described fascist and a rabid anti-Semite. And he set up armed militia groups around the country among his followers. Good guy. Was there a remedy that came from this that we could perhaps learn from to offset what we're dealing with?
里面讲了更多关于查尔斯·科夫林（Charles Coughlin）和林德伯格的内容。是的。所以科夫林是美国历史上出现过的最大的媒体人物。他是一个自称的法西斯分子和狂热的反犹太主义者。他在全国各地的追随者中建立了好战的民兵组织。真是个好人。有没有什么从这件事中得出的应对方法，我们可以从中吸取教训，来抵消我们现在正在处理的问题？
Dude, we tried. I mean, I don't know if you've seen, but there's been other people who've come in and take over the media. And they're not necessarily American. Oh, yeah. And it's like you were saying, we keep making the same fucking mistake. What is the change? What is the change that needs to happen? Yeah, how did they get through it then that maybe we could kind of draft off now?
老兄，我们试过了。我是说，我不知道你们有没有注意到，但有其他人进场接管了媒体。而且他们不一定是美国人。哦，是的。这就好像你们刚才说的，我们一直在犯同样的狗屁错误。到底需要发生什么改变？是的，他们当年是怎么挺过来的，也许我们现在可以借鉴一下？
That's why I wrote the book is that I actually think there's a bunch of like lessons learned, things to, post it notes, things to remember for 80 years from now and this comes around again. I mean, obviously the Nazis are, there's nobody like the Nazis. That's not the analogy. The analogy is a domestic government. That was their slogan. That's a hat.
这就是我写这本书的原因，我其实认为这里面有一堆经验教训，有些事，就像便利贴一样，有些事需要从现在起记住80年，当这种情况再次卷土重来时。我是说，很明显纳粹是——没有人能和纳粹相比。那不是类比。这个类比是一个国内政府。那是他们的口号。那是一顶帽子。
That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat.
那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。
That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. That's a hat. maybe a, um, uh, a, anoculate ourselves from a possible future or, or, or, are there many small things? It's, it's that there can't just be one thing. And so there, it's just, everything has to happen at once.
那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。那是一顶帽子。也许是，嗯，为我们自己接种疫苗，以防范可能的未来，或者，或者，或者有许多小事情？关键在于不能只有一件事。所以，一切都必须同时发生。
So there has to be, when it's crimes, when there's violence, there has to be prosecution, like the criminal justice system has a role. And it's really important to protect them from being intimidated. The risk of violence that I was talking about in the 1944 sedition trial, which I write about in the book, the attorney general was actually pressured by a senator who was implicated in the plot, was pressured by that senator into firing the prosecutor in that case. Like it worked, like that's terrible. We have to make sure the Justice Department and the legal system is protected from intimidation. But then it's also activism, people infiltrating these groups,
所以，当有犯罪，当有暴力时，必须进行起诉，就像刑事司法系统扮演着一个角色一样。保护他们免受恐吓真的非常重要。我在书中写到的1944年煽动叛乱审判中谈到了暴力的风险，总检察长实际上受到了卷入该阴谋的一名参议员的施压，被迫解雇了该案的检察官。这真的奏效了，这太可怕了。我们必须确保司法部和法律系统免受恐吓。但除此之外，还有激进主义、人们渗透进这些组织、
good journalism about it, you need the military, to court martial people, you need the bar associations and churches to police their ranks. When the Catholic Church is who shut down Fr. Cogland and had they not, he'd still be preaching anti-Semitism all through World War II. So you're saying that we could live in a world where a president could escape punishment because potentially like the Southern District of New York would refuse to...
关于此事的优秀新闻报道，你需要军方来对人们进行军事法庭审判，你需要律师协会和教堂来整顿他们的队伍。当年是天主教教会关闭了科夫林神父的节目，如果不是他们，他会在整个二战期间继续宣扬反犹太主义。所以你是说，我们可能会生活在这样一个世界里：一个总统可以逃脱惩罚，因为可能类似于纽约南区检察官办公室会拒绝……
I mean, I'm just... Look, I'm trying to... I'm dealing in hypotheticals here. Well, maybe what might be even more apt, another book that you wrote, bag man, correct me if I'm wrong, is the spear agnew that there was a deal offered him that may or may not potentially be a precedent for what could shape the possible conclusion
我是说，我只是——听着，我在探讨——我在这里讨论的是假设情况。好吧，也许更贴切的是你写的另一本书，《提包客》（Bag Man），如果我没记错的话，那是关于斯皮罗·阿格纽（Spiro Agnew）的，当时曾向他提供了一项协议，这可能或可能不构成某种先例，可以塑造可能的结局
of any sort of Trump sentencing? Well, what happened with Agnew is that they hit him with a 40 count federal indictment, which sounded amazing at the time. And now we're up in the 90-something count federal indictment and so he sounds like a piker. But yeah, they're hitting him with that felony indictment
对特朗普任何形式的判决会产生什么影响？好吧，阿格纽的遭遇是，他们对他提出了40项联邦罪名起诉，在当时听起来非常惊人。现在我们的联邦起诉罪名已经上升到90多项了，所以他听起来像个小角色。但是的，他们用重罪起诉他，
and he so didn't want to go to jail that his very able lawyers negotiated a deal where he plead no-low, he plead effectively no contest to one felony. And he would avoid jail time, but the penalty was that he had to resign from office. And agreeing never to go into politics again, correct? You know, I asked the prosecutors who were involved in that
而他太不想进监狱了，以至于他能力极强的律师谈判达成了一项协议：他以不抗辩（no contest）的方式对一项重罪认罪。他将避免牢狱之灾，但惩罚是他必须辞去公职。并且同意永远不再涉足政治，对吧？你知道的，我问过参与其中的检察官
if that was a contingency, if they said, you can never run again. And they said, we'd ever thought that we would ever have to put that in writing because who would ever think of voting for somebody who'd been charged with that? No, but wasn't this right at the moment where they were pretty sure Nixon was either going to resign or be impeached and that spirit agni with all of these, what was a tax fraud or something like that, the possibility was strong that he could end up in jail as a result of that prosecution,
这是否是一个附带条件，他们是否说过“你永远不能再次参选”？他们说，我们从没想过我们竟然需要把这一条写进文字里，因为谁会去投票给一个被指控犯有这种罪行的人呢？不，但这不正是那种时刻吗？当时他们非常确信尼克松要么辞职，要么被弹劾，而斯皮罗·阿格纽涉及所有这些——那是什么，税务欺诈还是别的什么——很有可能由于那场起诉，他最终会锒铛入狱
but then be appointed president because Nixon was on his way out and they didn't want a president to be incarcerated because it would just be a nightmare. So they offered him this deal. Am I getting any of that? This whole idea that you can't bring a prosecution against a sitting president. Yeah. That whole idea really was crystallized and formalized at the Justice Department around Nixon and Agnew because the Attorney General at the time, Elliot Richardson, is one of the people who was getting like middle of the night drunk in phone calls from Nixon, ranting and raving and seeming like a crazy person.
但随后因尼克松下台而被任命为总统，他们不希望前总统入狱，因为那将是一场噩梦。所以他们给他提供了这笔交易。我这么理解对吗？整个这种不能起诉在任总统的想法。对。这个想法实际上是在尼克松和阿格纽事件期间在司法部被确化和正式化的，因为当时的司法部长埃利奥特·理查森是那些接到尼克松半夜醉酒电话的人之一，尼克松在电话里大吵大闹，看起来像个疯子。
You are. The Attorney General thought he was in such bad shape that he was gonna die. And that Agnew was gonna be elevated. And it was tax evasion, but it was also bribery and extortion and all these other corruption crimes. And they thought, my God, we've got to figure out a way to get him out of there. But there's also nothing they probably never imagined
没错。司法部长认为他情况糟糕透顶，快要死了。而阿格纽将会取而代之。这不仅关乎逃税，还涉及受贿、敲诈勒索以及所有这些其他的腐败罪行。他们心想，天哪，我们必须想个办法把他弄下台。但他们可能也永远无法想象
at Rachel because there was a thing back that people had that was called shame. We just certain point. And now where the people are so ashamed. I just felt it, just. Yeah, yeah, where they'd say, they'd be like, even a guy like, he's like, I'm not gonna fight. I'm not gonna go fucking do that.
蕾切尔，因为当时人们还有一种叫做羞耻心的东西。我们在某个特定节点。而现在人们已经毫无羞耻感了。我只是有这种感觉，对，对，他们会说，他们会表现得，甚至像某个人，他会说，我不会抗争。我特么才不干那种事。
I can't do that. That's indecent at the highest level. I've done a bunch of other shit, but doing that, now it doesn't matter. All of that is out the window because of, you know. Yeah, my, my, I think assume that, you know. I think such a dumb, dumb question. All of that is out the window because of, you know, you have my fancy suit. I think such a dumb, dumb question to all of this is like, why do people go into politics?
我不能那么做。那是极其不道德的。我干过其他一堆破事，但干那件事，现在无所谓了。这一切都因为，你知道的。没错，我，我，我想当然地认为，你知道的。我觉得这是一个极其愚蠢、极其愚蠢的问题。这一切都因为，你知道的，你穿着我那套华丽的西装。我觉得所有这一切背后一个极其愚蠢、极其愚蠢的问题是：人们为什么要去从政？
I don't understand. The second you get elected, you got to target on your back and then they're involved in everything we're talking about where I'm going to get you. I'm going to sue you. I'm going to sue you. And it's just, it seems like an endless game of that. I mean, you can do good stuff in politics.
我不理解。你一当选，背上就成了一个靶子，然后他们就会卷入我们正在谈论的所有事情中，比如我要搞垮你。我要起诉你。我要起诉你。这看起来就像是一场没完没了的游戏。我是说，你能在政治上做好事。
Yeah, I mean. Government can do good things, but a lot of people go into politics because they want power and they want ego. You know, they don't have a very good structure. It's certainly not for the money, right? Doesn't average, the senator make far, far less, probably a tenth of what they could make in the private sector, being a lawyer. Most of these senators would be the top lawyer in their district, So they're taking a big pay cut. So it must just
对，我是说。政府可以做好事，但很多人从政是因为他们想要权力和自我。你知道，他们的心理结构不太好。当然不是为了钱，对吧？难道一个参议员的平均收入不远低于——很可能是他们在私营部门当律师时收入的十分之一吗？这些参议员大多会是他们那个地区顶尖的律师，所以他们接受了大幅度的减薪。所以这一定只是
go down. Although they all seem to do very well after they leave office. Yeah, no kidding. Yeah, yeah. You've seen a poor ex-senator. Yeah, yeah. What do they call a manenta? They go gold bar Bobby or something? Now, all, well, Rachel, let's go back. Let's go back to the volleyball and basketball days. And getting sort of the, now your father was Air Force, I believe, and your mom was in education. So yeah. Yeah, OK.
下降。尽管他们在离职后似乎都混得风生水起。对，说得没错。是啊，是啊。你见过哪个前参议员过得穷困潦倒的吗？是啊，是啊。他们怎么称呼梅嫩德斯？叫他“金条鲍比”什么的？现在，好吧，蕾切尔，让我们回到过去。让我们回到排球和篮球的年代。然后，现在你父亲好像是空军，我没记错吧，你妈妈是做教育的。所以，是的。是的，没问题。
So then she worked at the middle school. OK. But there was clearly, there was that great sort of cocktail of those two things at the dinner table for you to start get interested in those worlds. Yes, and did politics was it an early passion or do you find it later? No, not at all.
所以她后来在初中工作。好的。但显然，在你餐桌上这两种特质完美地融合在了一起，让你开始对那些世界产生兴趣。是的，政治是你早期的一种热情，还是你后来才发现的？不，完全不是。
It's interesting. I didn't, we weren't like a kid's book kind of family. We didn't have that, that wasn't the vibe. My mom is from, grew up on a farm very poor in Northeastern Canada. My dad was the first person in his family to go to college. I'm on the roll. Where do you say, well, where do you say, where do you say, where do you say, where do you go?
这很有意思。我没有，我们可不是那种看儿童读物的家庭，我们家没有那种氛围。我妈妈来自，在加拿大东北部的一个农场长大，非常贫穷。我爸爸是他家里第一个上大学的人。我一直在说。你是在哪儿说的，呃，你是在哪儿说的，你是在哪儿说的，你是在哪儿说的，你要去哪儿？
Where do you say, where do you say, where do you say, where do you go? Where do you say, where do you say, where do you say, where do you say, where do you go? Oh. Your mom's Canadian. Here we go. She's from Newfoundland. She's from Newfoundland? Yes. Oh, they're by, I'm going to say, you know, I'm Canadian from Toronto. We're going to say hi to all of our buddies out there, Newfoundland, there by, hey, there. Hey, Torre Bay, hey, Gander.
你是在哪儿说的，呃，你是在哪儿说的，你是在哪儿说的，你是在哪儿说的，你要去哪儿？你是在哪儿说的，呃，你是在哪儿说的，你是在哪儿说的，你是在哪儿说的，你要去哪儿？哦。你妈妈是加拿大人。这就对了。她来自纽芬兰。她来自纽芬兰？是的。哦，他们是那里的，我要说，你知道，我是来自多伦多的加拿大人。我们要向纽芬兰的所有老朋友们问好，你们好啊，嘿。嘿，托尔贝，嘿，甘德。
No way. Yeah. That's amazing. Yeah, big family, lots of sisters who are nuns. She didn't want to be a nun, didn't want to be a nurse, afraid of the sight of blood, and didn't want to be a nun, didn't want to be a nurse, afraid of the sight of blood, and didn't want to be a teacher, didn't much like children. So she left, came to the United States,
真的吗？是的。太棒了。是的，大家庭，有很多当修女的姐妹。她不想当修女，不想当护士，一看到血就害怕，她不想当修女，不想当护士，一看到血就害怕，她也不想当老师，不太喜欢小孩子。所以她离开了，来到美国，
ended up meeting my dad when he was in the Air Force. But yeah, I grew up reading the newspaper. It was more interested in news. But then by the time I was figuring out who I was in my teenage years, it was the real height of the AIDS crisis, and I was coming out as gay and I was growing up in the San Francisco Bay area. So I got really swept up in AIDS activism really early on. Did you guys talk about current events and stuff at the dinner table?
后来在我爸爸在空军服役时遇到了他。不过，是的，我从小读报纸。我对新闻更感兴趣。但到了我十几岁开始寻找自我的时候，正值艾滋病危机的顶峰，我出柜了，而且我在旧金山湾区长大。所以我很早就深深地卷入了艾滋病激进主义活动中。你们在餐桌上会谈论时事之类的话题吗？
Were you that family? Were you talked about what was going on? No. Not really. It wasn't really like that. No. I mean, my parents are fantastic. They're my favorite people in the world. But it just wasn't that kind of a vibe. Like I think they were as surprised as I was. I also didn't start doing anything in the news media until after I was almost done with
你们是那种家庭吗？你们会谈论正在发生的事情吗？不。其实不会。真的不是那种氛围。不。我是说，我父母非常棒。他们是我世界上最喜欢的人。但就不是那种氛围。我觉得他们和我一样感到惊讶。直到我快完成
my graduate degree. I just was on a totally different plane. My first news job was I did an open on air audition to be the news girl on the morning zoo radio show To town that I was growing up in no way dry time no original matter on the morning. So is the greatest news girl was my title All right, we're here with the weasel and Woody in here with the weasel and the Woody and here with Rachel. Here you go. Wait, Sean, your dad was in the air for it, right? Yeah.
研究生学位之后，我才开始在新闻媒体工作。我完全处于另一个轨道上。我的第一份新闻工作是，我参加了一场公开的电台试音，想成为我长大的那个镇上的早间动物园广播节目的“新闻女孩”。没门，干旱时期，早间节目里根本没有原创内容。所以最棒的“新闻女孩”就是我的头衔。好了，我们和黄鼠狼、伍迪在一起，和黄鼠狼、伍迪在一起，还有蕾切尔。给你。等等，肖恩，你爸爸以前在空军，对吧？是的。
He took off. No, not just because he took off. Yeah, he took off. That's why I thought that. Rachel, what drew you to like want to even do that? What drew you to be like, oh my God, I want to be, I want to try that zoo news girl news review. It was a dare.
他飞走了。不，不只是因为他飞走了。对，他飞走了。这就是我这么想的原因。蕾切尔，是什么吸引你想去做那个？是什么吸引你觉得，哦天哪，我想成为，我想尝试那个动物园新闻女孩的新闻评论。那是一个大冒险。
I was staying with friends. Zoo news. I was, I was staying with friends and I was staying with friends and I was doing odd jobs and I was terrible at all of them. I was doing deliveries, but I had a car with an electrical problem. So, every, unless I could leave my car running and it would not stall out, I could, I needed a jump every time. I had to go to a new door. I got a park on the hill, pop the fludge. I was really bad at that. I had to come too. I was, I worked at, friends had a coffee roasting company and I installed some plumbing backwards in their plant and made a faucet blow up.
我和朋友们住在一起。动物园新闻。我，我当时和朋友们住在一起，我，我当时和朋友们住在一起，做着各种零工，而且我干每一样都糟糕透顶。我负责送货，但我有一辆电路有问题的车。所以，每一次，除非我让车一直着火不熄火，否则我每次都需要搭电才能重新启动。我必须去一扇新门前。我得把车停在山坡上，弹起舱盖。我那方面真的很烂。我还得去。我曾在，朋友们开了一家咖啡烘焙公司，我在他们的工厂里把一些管道装反了，导致一个水龙头爆炸了。
And I just had a really bad job. It's on my friends who I was staying with said, oh, this morning show we listen to, they're doing this audition. And I auditioned live on the air and I got hired on the spot and started the next day. And I just loved it from the. I was just reading associated press like Rip and Read, top of the hour news copy. And you just couldn't get enough. Yeah, that's so cool. Amazing. But then though I'm going to jump way forward then now flashing forward you find yourself as a
我当时的工作运真的很背。收留我的朋友说：“哦，我们听的这个早间节目，他们在招募试音。”然后我在节目里进行了现场试音，当场就被录用了，第二天就开始上班。我从一开始就爱上了它。我只是在读美联社的即兴新闻稿，整点新闻稿。你就是听不够。是的，太酷了。太棒了。但随后，我要把时间大大地向前推进了，现在快进到你发现自己成了
panelist on Tucker Carlson show on MSNBC. And how I don't remember him on MSNBC, I, you came on my radar when I was, because I was a big, big still am an Obermann fan. You were, you were on there often. And, but what was it, was Tucker the same Tucker back then or was he on the left? No. He wasn't on the left. MSNBC wasn't really, I mean, Keith is what made MSNBC liberal, right?
MSNBC塔克·卡尔森节目的嘉宾。我不记得他在MSNBC上过节目，我，你进入我的视线是因为，我曾是一个超级、超级、现在依然是奥伯曼的粉丝。你以前经常上他的节目。但是，当时是怎样的？当时的塔克还是那个塔克，还是他是左翼？不。他当时不是左翼。MSNBC当时其实并不是，我是说，基斯让MSNBC变得倾向自由派，对吧？
He showed, he did great. He sort of came out as a liberal, did a great job. This is incredible broadcasting talent. Yeah. And he, with especially the special comments, kind of created, cut the path through the jungle in terms of making MSNBC have kind of a liberal identity. Before that, it really didn't.
他的节目很棒。他以自由派的身份出现，干得非常出色。这是一位令人难以置信的广播天才。是的。而且他，尤其是通过那些特别评论，在让MSNBC拥有自由派身份这方面，可以说是披荆斩棘。在此之前，它真的没有这种身份。
And so Tucker doing the late night show on MSNBC, it was, like MSNBC was just politics. It wasn't any one lane in politics. I think it might have been his immediate post-Botai job. Like I don't think it was, I think it was post-Botai. Post-Botai, yeah. That's the delineation. I think that he became the Tucker that we all ended up knowing when he realized how well it paid to be that guy. And I know that's a cynical
所以塔克在MSNBC主持深夜节目时，就好像MSNBC播的只是政治节目。它并不局限于政治中的某一个方向。我想这可能紧接着他不再系领结的工作之后。我觉得不是，我觉得那是系领结之后的事。系领结之后，是的。这就是分水岭。我想他之所以变成了我们后来认识那个塔克，是因为他意识到当那种人有多赚钱。我知道这听起来很讽刺，
thing, but I truly believe that. I don't know the guy at all, but I'm really good at judging people harshly. It's kind of a talent. You hear me talk about Elon Musk, but I will say. I love that. I will say, let me ask you, Rachel, when it comes to Tucker, do you miss him? I'm real busy. Yeah, I know. Well, that's good. Hey, and Bill O'Reilly must be doing something, but thank God that Keith came along and exposed us all to you and was such a big advocate for you. And you ended up being on a key show quite a bit and then guest hosting for him quite a bit
但我深信不疑。我根本不认识这个人，但我非常擅长严厉地评判别人。这算是一种天赋。你听我谈论埃隆·马斯克就知道了，但我必须说。我喜欢这样。我得说，请问你，蕾切尔，说到塔克，你怀念他吗？我很忙。是的，我知道。好吧，这很好。嘿，比尔·奥赖利肯定也在做些什么，但谢天谢地，基斯出现了，让我们所有人都认识了你，并且一直是你的超级支持者。你最后成了基斯节目的常驻嘉宾，后来还经常为他代班主持，
and enjoying it and him enjoying you and MSNBC enjoying you. And then your show took off, yes? Yeah, so it was interesting. One of the things that Keith did for me was he said, you should use my agent, and I never do that. I stopped my agent from representing anybody who I compete against, but you should use my agent,
并且你很享受，他也喜欢你，MSNBC也很喜欢你。然后你的节目就火了，对吧？对，所以这很有趣。基斯为我做的事情之一就是他说：“你应该用我的经纪人，”而我从来不这样做。我阻止我的经纪人代理任何与我竞争的人，但你应该用我的经纪人，
which was a very generous thing. And she's fantastic. Her name's Jean Sage. She was my agent forever and ever and ever. And Jean convinced the president of MSNBC Phil Griffin to hire me, and the fact that I had done so well and perceived who have done well on Keith's show,
这是一件非常慷慨的事情。而且她非常棒。她叫简·萨奇。她做我的经纪人做了漫长无比的岁月。简说服了MSNBC的总裁菲尔·格里芬雇用我，而我在基斯的节目中表现得那么好、被认为表现得很出色这一事实，
I think was absolutely the on-ramp there. But then I started at nine o'clock right after the 2008 election, or right at the 2008 election. And then that's what I've been doing ever since. Only recently did I scale back from five days to one day, but this is, we just turned 15. Yeah, that's awesome. Congratulations. It's a great, great accomplishment. Yeah, and, but now you're leaving yourself open to pursue
我认为绝对是其中的敲门砖。然后我在2008年大选刚结束的九点档开始主持，或者说正赶上2008年大选。从那以后我一直干到现在。直到最近我才把工作时间从每周五天缩减到每周一天，不过，我们刚迎来了15周年台庆。太棒了。恭喜。这是一个了不起的伟大成就。是的，而且，但现在你让自己有机会去追求
all the many other things that you're doing with the writing and the podcasting and, and, et cetera. And also finding time to live a life and fish with Susan. And, right? And what do you guys do something? So that's your way. Yeah, you're comfortable telling us that it just dums it all down. I mean, are you waiting with Bated Breath for the Golden Bachelors? Crap like that?
你一直在做的许多其他事情，比如写作、做播客等等。并且还能抽出时间去生活，和苏珊一起钓鱼。对吧？你们平时做什么？所以那是你的方式。是的，你很乐意告诉我们，这让我们彻底放松下来。我是说，你是不是在翘首以盼《黄金单身汉》这样的垃圾节目？
I say with all respect. We are such old. I think it's as much respect as you can muster. What do you guys do to dumb it down? We are, are you familiar with the Great British Baking Show? Yes, of course. Yes. I think it's the greatest television show I've ever made,
我这是怀着十二万分的敬意说的。我们都已经老成这样了。我想这已经算是你能拿出的全部敬意了。你们平时做什么来放松大脑？我们，你们熟悉《英国烘焙大赛》吗？是的，当然。是的。我认为这是我有生以来看过最棒的电视节目，
but I also haven't watched much television. No. So I don't know, but it's my perfect drug. It's my perfect drug. Does it get you then to the kitchen to try your talents at the same stuff? Oh no, I can only make drinks. Do you read a book while you're watching TV? What's your favorite drink? If someone's going to bring you a bottle of something as a gift, you're coming over to Rachel's house for dinner. What do they want to bring you? Is it wine? Is it? Yeah, I mean, I'm kind of, I don't drink vodka, but other than that, I'm pretty good.
不过我其实也不怎么看电视。不。所以我不知道，但它对我有如致命的诱惑。它就是我完美的精神慰藉。那它会让你走进厨房去尝试自己做那些东西吗？哦不，我只会调酒。你看电视的时候会看书吗？你最喜欢什么酒？如果有人要送你一瓶什么东西作为礼物，你准备去蕾切尔家吃晚饭。他们应该带什么来？是葡萄酒吗？是吗？对，我是说，我基本上，我不喝伏特加，除此之外，我都挺喜欢的。
I'm pretty, I'm pretty equal opportunity. But you know, I also feel like I need to be. What's the vodka story? At what point was someone holding your hair after vodka? No. I just don't like it. It tastes like a cleaning product to me. You know how like some people have that with cilantro?
我这人，我这人还挺随和的。不过你知道，我也觉得我需要。伏特加那个故事是怎么回事？什么时候有人在喝完伏特加后扶着你的头发吐？不。我只是不喜欢它。对我来说它尝起来像清洁剂。你知道有些人对香菜也有这种感觉吗？
And people always say like, oh, vodka has no flavor. I'm like, it does. And it tastes like you should be to me. You know how like some people have that with cilantro? And people always say like, Oh, vodka has no flavor. I'm like, it does. And it tastes like you should be. It's under the rim. It's amazing. I have this image of you and your partner Susan because our friend Eli is a friend of all of ours. He used to always say we'd watch you
人们总是说，哦，伏特加没有味道。而我说，它有。它尝起来就像你应该。你知道有些人对香菜也有这种感觉吗？人们总是说，哦，伏特加没有味道。而我说，它有。它尝起来就像你应该。它在边缘之下。太神奇了。我脑海里一直有这样一个画面，你和你的伴侣苏珊，因为我们的朋友伊莱是我们共同的朋友。他以前总是说，我们在亚特兰大时会看你的节目，诸如此类。
when we were in Atlanta, whatever. And he'd say, I just want to go to Rachel's house and have coffee in the morning and have her just talk me through everything that's going on. Just that's going on and just make me feel okay and break everything down because there's so much information that just want her I just want to sit on her porch I go yeah Eli I don't think that's gonna happen buddy but also that's not what coffee with me is like it's the different it's a pretty nonverbal experience until I'm into cup two you know you know what Rachel you know I find
然后他说，我只想去蕾切尔家，早上喝杯咖啡，听她跟我讲讲发生的一切。听她讲正在发生的事情，让我感觉一切都好，把所有事情都剖析清楚，因为有太多的信息，我只想让她——我只想坐在她的门廊上。我说，好吧，伊莱，我觉得这不会发生，老兄。而且，和我喝咖啡可不是那样的，那基本上是一个相当非语言交流的体验，直到我喝完第二杯，你知道的，你知道吗，蕾切尔，你知道我发现
interesting what I really enjoy is watching you, when you do, when you're on TV and you're talking about a subject, your cadence is second to none because it's often quite broken up and you take pauses that I, what I've sort of gleaned from your pauses that you're thinking, which is extraordinary.
有趣的是什么吗？我最喜欢看你的是，当你在电视上谈论某个话题时，你的节奏堪称一流，因为你的语速常常相当断续，而且你会停顿，从你的停顿中我推断出你在思考，这太了不起了。
Because a lot of people just catch up, though. Well, yeah, it's suggesting that there's no prompt or for whatever subject that is that you're kind of using on, and that we live in a world where people are so quick to have an answer. It's not just about being right, it's about how quick you can be right. And it's so odd, and I think it's so powerful to take a moment
因为很多人只是随口附和。好吧，是的，这表明没有提词器，不管你讨论的是什么主题，你都在思考。我们生活在一个人们急于给出答案的世界里。这不仅关乎正确与否，还关乎你能以多快的速度给出正确答案。这太奇怪了，我认为在谈论某事时花上一刻钟去真正思考，然后再开口，是一件非常有力量的事。正如人们所说的，去年我们在播客里采访拜登总统时，
when you're talking about something to really think about it before you, it's kind of the thing when people say when we had Biden on last year on our podcast, the president Biden, and people say, well, what was he like? And I said, you know what? He's a really thoughtful guy. And yes, he's a little bit, he's older than we are.
总统拜登，人们问，他是个什么样的人？我说，你知道吗？他是一个非常体贴周到的人。是的，他有点，他比我们年龄要大。
However, I do like the idea of somebody who's in that position. Taking a minute to think about it, when presented with a problem. And that is something that is really undervalued. And I think I see you do it in real time. And I find it very interesting. It's very powerful, right? Yeah, very well said. Well, I mean, I think it's important do it in real time, and I find it very interesting, it's very powerful. Right? Yeah, very well said. Well, I mean, I think it's important not to
然而，我很喜欢这种想法：身处那个位置的人，在面对问题时，会花上一分钟去思考。而这是一种被严重低估的品质。我想我看到你在实时展现这一点。我觉得这非常有趣，非常有力量，对吧？是的，说得太好了。嗯，我是说，我觉得重要的是不要
black through stuff that you don't know. If you don't know, it's okay. Like, it better, don't make it up, it's okay. We can find somebody else who does have the answer if you don't. Yeah. But even if you're being asked your opinion on something, I think there isn't value to just like singing it out in the right tempo.
对你不知道的事情不懂装懂。如果你不知道，没关系。最好别瞎编，没关系。如果你不知道，我们可以找别人来解答。是的。但即使别人问你对某事的看法，我觉得按照合适的节奏把想法斟酌着说出来也是有价值的。
You have to, there's has to be a reason that you're there. There has to be a reason that you're worthy of being asked and worthy of the attention. It's why I don't put on, I never on my shows, I never put on people to fight. And if somebody lies on the show, I don't invite them back, that I feel like I'm offering my audience a chance to hear from somebody
你必须，你坐在那里必须得有个理由。你必须有理由让人觉得向你提问是值得的，并且值得获得关注。这就是为什么我从不，在我的节目里，我从不在节目里安排别人吵架。如果有人在节目里撒谎，我就不会再邀请他们回来，因为我觉得我是在为观众提供一个倾听某人发言的机会，
because I think they have something valuable to say. All right, I'll do it. Enhance, all right. I understand. I can see. Yes. Boy, you really misplaced that, Sean. I'm sorry.
因为我认为他们有有价值的话要说。好吧，我来做。加强，好的。我明白了。我能看出来。是的。天哪，肖恩，你可真把那段搞砸了。我很抱歉。
She was... We'll be right back. Thank you to Audible for their support. We'll be right back. celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, and more. As an audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog of thousands of titles. I can tell you, I've been looking at all these incredible titles. I mean, listen, if they're all as good as the covers look, and now I'm trying not to judge a book by the cover, but I've got, I'm thinking about just planning
她当时是……我们马上回来。感谢Audible对本节目的支持。我们马上回来。名人回忆录、悬疑惊悚片、励志、健康、商业等等。作为Audible的会员，你可以从数千部作品的整个目录中每月挑选一部作品永久保留。我必须告诉你，我一直在看这些令人难以置信的书名。我是说，听着，如果它们的内涵都和封面看起来一样棒的话，现在我正努力做到不以貌取书，但我有了，我正在考虑仅仅为了听书
vacations just to listen to books. So I'm going to get back to you when I settle on the vacation spot and book. Maybe we can all meet there. New members can try audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smart list or text smart list to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smart list or text smart list to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smart list or text smart list to 500-500 to tri-audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smart list.
而计划度假。所以等我确定了度假地点和书目后，我会再联系你们。也许我们可以在那里碰面。新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。访问audible.com/smartlist或发送短信smartlist到500-500。网址是audible.com/smartlist，或者发送短信smartlist到500-500。再次重申，访问audible.com/smartlist或发送短信smartlist到500-500即可免费试用Audible 30天。audible.com/smartlist。
Hello, listener Jason here. November is diabetes awareness month. Did you know that? A time to bring attention to diabetes. So let's talk about it. I know it's not fun or sexy, but hang on. Let me just let me finish. Managing diabetes requires a lot of effort and unfortunately a lot of people living with it don't feel understood because not many people know what it really takes to manage the condition. Well, that's where metronic diabetes comes in. Metronic makes devices to manage diabetes
听众朋友们好，我是杰森。11月是糖尿病意识月。你知道吗？这是一个引起人们对糖尿病关注的时刻。所以我们来聊聊吧。我知道这既不好玩也不迷人，但等一下。让我把话说完。管理糖尿病需要付出巨大的努力，不幸的是，许多与糖尿病共存的人并没有感到被理解，因为没有多少人真正知道管理这种疾病需要付出什么。这就是美敦力糖尿病公司（Medtronic Diabetes）切入的地方。美敦力制造管理糖尿病的设备，
and they're very passionate about supporting the community, which is why they launch their blue balloon challenge to raise awareness. The balloon represents the mental load and constant decision making that people living with diabetes are faced with. It's a constant balancing act trying to keep blood sugars and range while living their life.
他们对支持这个社区充满热情，这就是他们发起“蓝色气球挑战”（Blue Balloon Challenge）来提高意识的原因。气球代表着糖尿病患者所面临的精神负担和不断的决策过程。在过日常生活的同时，试图将血糖保持在正常范围内，这是一场持续的平衡表演。
Medtronic diabetes wants you to join the challenge and help them spread awareness and support for the diabetes community. So grab a blue balloon and try to keep it in the air while doing everyday things in your life. Tag at Medtronic Diabetes on social media and use the hashtag blue balloon challenge. We can all come together to help make the invisible visible. Visit MedTronicDiabetes.com slash smartlis to learn more. That's MedTronicDiabetes.com slash smartlis.
美敦力糖尿病公司希望你加入这项挑战，帮助他们传播对糖尿病社区的认知和支持。所以，拿一个蓝色气球，在做日常生活的点点滴滴时试着把它留在空中。在社交媒体上标记@Medtronic Diabetes并使用话题#蓝色气球挑战（blue balloon challenge）。我们齐心协力，就能让隐形的疾病被看见。访问MedtronicDiabetes.com/smartlist了解更多信息。网址是MedTronicDiabetes.com/smartlis。
Hey smartlis listeners, this episode is supported by Kraft Heinz. If your home tailgate gathering has started to feel a little rerun, then guess what? These delicious brands can be used to make new recipes to serve as part of your football food traditions. For me, I'm actually, you know, newly kind of into football. I've kind of always been into football, but now I'm really into it. And I actually have friends over and we watch the games.
嘿，smartless的听众们，本集节目由卡夫亨氏（Kraft Heinz）赞助支持。如果你家里的观赛派对开始让人觉得像是在重播老节目，那么猜怎么着？这些美味的品牌可以用来制作新的食谱，作为你橄榄球美食传统的一部分。对我来说，其实，你知道的，我最近刚刚迷上橄榄球。我以前其实一直挺喜欢橄榄球的，但现在我是真的迷上了。我实际上会邀请朋友来家里一起看比赛。
I know me, I know. It's true though, go chiefs, go 49ers. See, I know what I'm talking about. I know who's at the top. But my favorite ones are craft singles and craft mac and cheese. First of all, Beneteen craft mac and cheese since I was a kid.
了解我的人都知道。不过这是真的，加油酋长，加油49人。看，我知道我在说什么。我知道谁在顶峰。但我最喜欢的还是卡夫单片奶酪（Kraft Singles）和卡夫通心粉配奶酪（Kraft Mac and Cheese）。首先，我从小就吃卡夫通心粉配奶酪。
It's one of those things that when you make it, everybody feels like, you know, oh, I'm home again, right? So on game day, I make like three or four boxes of craft mac and cheese, because I can eat one on my own, but it's enough to go around. And then craft singles constantly make grilled. I make the best grilled cheese sandwiches
这是那种当你做好它时，每个人都会觉得，你知道的，“哦，我又回到家了”的东西，对吧？所以在比赛日，我会做三四盒卡夫通心粉配奶酪，因为我一个人就能吃一盒，但这些足够大家分着吃了。而且卡夫单片奶酪总是能用来做烤芝士。我用卡夫单片奶酪能做出最棒的
using craft singles. Truly, it's the best. Come over, I'll make one for you. It's your turn to show off your tasty game day food traditions. Go to gamedayfoodtraditions.com to share a photo of your game day food tradition to enter to win $10,000. That's gamedayfoodtraditions.com.
烤芝士三明治。真的，这是最棒的。过来吧，我给你做一个。现在轮到你展示自己美味的比赛日美食传统了。访问 gamedayfoodtraditions.com 分享你比赛日美食传统的照片，即有机会赢得10,000美元。网址是 gamedayfoodtraditions.com。
All right, back to the show. Wait Rachel, do you think because, and then we, I want to get back more to you, but do you think now is the time more than ever in a long, long time for an independent to win next year? Because it doesn't seem like the, what I'm feeling is people aren't excited about one side, but a lot of the people seem like they're not excited about either side. And I thought, well, gosh, when it perfect storm for somebody to break through right in the middle and run as an independent. We really have a de facto two-party democracy, though. And so trying to bring about an independent candidacy at a practical level, all you're
好了，回到节目中。等等，蕾切尔，你觉得——然后我们，我想更多地回到你身上——你觉得现在是不是很久很久以来，最适合独立候选人在明年赢得大选的时机？因为人们似乎对，我的感觉是人们对其中一边并不兴奋，但很多人似乎对两边都不兴奋。我想，天哪，这不正是某个局外人突破重围、以独立身份参选的完美风暴吗？不过，我们实际上实行的是事实上的两党民主制。因此，要在实际层面上发起独立参选，你所做的全部事情，
doing is deciding which of the two parties you want to have that proportion of the vote shaved off of. So if you bring on an independent who's gonna appeal to Democratic candidates, you're just making it more likely that President Biden will lose. And if you bring on an independent candidate who's more attractive to Republicans, that you're making it more likely
只是决定了你想从哪一个政党那里分走那部分选票。所以，如果你推出一位会吸引民主党选民的独立候选人，你只会让拜登总统更有可能输掉选举。而如果你推出一位对共和党人更有吸引力的独立候选人，你就会让
that probably Trump will lose. So it ends up in real politic just being that. And we can reimagine the American political system using instant runoff voting and other things that are now being tried in some states so that there isn't that spoiler effect. But right now, while it exists, the only purpose of an independent candidate is to take votes away from the major party candidate who they're most likely. of an independent candidate is to take votes away from the major party candidate who they're most like. Well, there ever be a world in this country
特朗普更有可能输掉选举。所以在政治现实中，结果就是这样。我们可以利用即时决选投票和其他一些目前在某些州正在尝试的方法，来重新构想美国政治体系，这样就不会产生那种分票效应。但就目前而言，当这种效应存在时，独立候选人的唯一目的就是从他们最相似的主流政党候选人那里抢走选票。这个国家以后会不会出现这样一个世界：
where they will blow up the electoral college, that system. Will that ever happen? Maybe. I mean, there's all sorts of counter-majoritarian things, like things in our system that where the majority votes for a thing, but they still don't get it. That are starting to be really, I think,
他们会炸毁选举人团制度？这种情况会发生吗？也许会。我是说，系统里存在各种各样违背多数民意的机制，比如在我们体系中，多数人投票赞成某事，但他们却无法如愿以偿的情况。这些机制开始真的被那些想要不同类型少数统治的人，
overexploited by people who want different types of minority rules. So that's Jerry Mandering, that's the electoral college, that's other forms of abuse of the legislative system. The ways Congress are changing. Republicans, broadly speaking, are using them in ways that are against voting at a very level. You know, a Democrat selected governor of North Carolina. And so the Republicans in the North Carolina legislature
过度利用了。这就是杰利蝾螈（划分选区不公），这就是选举人团，这就是对立法系统其他形式的滥用。国会变化的方式。共和党人从宏观上讲，他们利用这些方式正在从根本上反对投票。你知道的，北卡罗来纳州选出了一个民主党州长。于是北卡罗来纳州立法机构的共和党人
take away all the powers that the governor has. Yeah. Yeah. Eventually, that kind of stuff reaches its limit. If we're going to be a democracy and not a country where you rule by force, then people are going to have to stand up for democracy. And that might mean the countermajoritarian stuff, like the Electoral College,
剥夺了州长拥有的所有权力。是啊。是啊。最终，这种把戏会达到它的极限。如果我们想要成为一个民主国家，而不是一个靠武力统治的国家，那么人们就必须挺身而出捍卫民主。这意味着那些违背多数民意的机制，比如选举人团，
is gonna get some pressure. And we're now seeing how vitally important it is to maintain control of the Supreme Court, and what happens when you don't. Yeah, and using underhanded and duplicitous and hypocritical tactics to get your majority on the Supreme Court, pays off for the life of the justices. underhanded and duplicitous and hypocritical tactics to get your majority on the Supreme Court pays off for the life of the justices. So that's a bad precedent to set
将会面临一些压力。我们现在看到保持对最高法院控制权的至关重要性，以及失去控制时会发生什么。是的，为了在最高法院获得多数席位而使用暗中操作、两面三刀和虚伪的战术，这会让大法官们在任期内终身受益。为了在最高法院获得多数席位而使用暗中操作、两面三刀和虚伪的战术，这会让大法官们在任期内终身受益。所以这是一个糟糕的先例，
because you've now set the bar that any means necessary for getting a justice onto the court is effectively justified by what the Republicans did. Right, and we're not talking about necessarily, by the way, it should be noted to our listeners or listeners who were put off by us talking in this way. We're not, we're not saying that having a conservative judge is bad. I'm really not suggesting it.
因为你们现在树立了这样一个标准：为了让一名大法官进入最高法院，任何手段都是必要的，这实际上被共和党人所做的事情合理化了。没错，而且我们不一定在谈论——顺便说一句，应该向我们的听众或那些对我们这种谈话感到反感的听众指出。我们不是，我们并不是说拥有一个保守派法官是坏事。我真的不是这个意思。
If it's done within the framework of what is fair, then that's fine. What we're talking about is rigging the system to, you know, affect the outcome. And when you do that, that is not fair. That is not a democracy working and it's best, it's, it's, it's functioning at its best. And you should also be opposed to that because we're to work against you. You'd, you'd feel very undermined and you'd feel very cheated. And you'd feel like this system is. But unfortunately, it seems like we're having to start, start to sort of workshop and brainstorm what else we can do now that fair
如果这一切是在公平框架内完成的，那很好。我们谈论的是操纵系统来，你知道的，影响结果。当你这么做时，那就不公平。那不是民主在运作，也不是它处于最佳状态，不是它以最佳状态运行。你也应该对此表示反对，因为如果这个系统转而对付你。你会觉得自己的根基被深深动摇，你会觉得自己被狠狠欺骗了。你会觉得这个系统是。但不幸的是，似乎我们不得不开始，开始对我们还能做些什么进行头脑风暴和研讨，因为在政治领域中，“公平”正变得越来越少见。
is becoming less and less common in the political space. And do we take the bait and start playing by their rules and thus sacrificing our own values and ethics? Or do we continue on the high road and get comfortable with the losses? You know, I'm not sure what the future is gonna hold for that. I feel like the lesson of history here is to have one load star, which is protect democracy.
我们是该吞下诱饵，开始按他们的规则行事，从而牺牲我们自己的价值观和道德？还是继续走高姿态，坦然接受失败？你知道的，我不确定未来会怎样。我觉得历史给我们的教训是：心中要有一颗北极星，那就是保护民主。
And that means make sure that everybody knows and everybody believes, and we reify every way we can that the way we solve problems in this country is through democratic process. And anything that is about, you know, what we're saying about the, you know, the fair process of, of which justice is ended up on the Supreme Court, if you vote for a conservative president, part of what you are voting for is if there is a vacancy on the Supreme Court, while that president in his office, that president will appoint a conservative to the court, or conversely, with a liberal.
这意味着要确保每个人都知道，每个人都坚信，并且我们要以一切可能的方式巩固这样一种理念：我们在国内解决问题的方式是通过民主程序。任何关于，你知道的，正如我们所说的那样，关于哪位大法官最终进入最高法院的公平程序，如果你投票给一位保守派总统，你投票的部分内容就是：如果最高法院出现空缺，在该总统任职期间，该总统将任命一名保守派进入最高法院；反之，对于自由派也是如此。
You are voting for a liberal president. It is with the understanding that if there's a vacancy, there'll be a liberal appointee. Right. When that system gets broken, you are separating outcomes from the vote and you are making people feel like the vote doesn't matter. And in fact, you are making it so their vote doesn't matter, which means our democracy is getting weaker. Whatever whoever wins or loses any particular fight, the connection between people's desire and the outcomes they get from their government Should always be the load star because that's the thing that's under assault from people who want authoritarianism and rule by force instead of rule by vote.
你投票支持一位自由派总统。这是在这样一种理解下进行的：如果有空缺，就会有自由派的任命人选。没错。当这个系统被打破时，你就是在将结果与投票结果割裂开来，你是在让人们觉得投票毫无意义。事实上，你正在让他们的投票变得毫无意义，这意味着我们的民主正在变弱。无论谁在任何特定的争端中赢得或输掉，人们的意愿与他们从政府那里获得的结果之间的联系，永远应该像北极星一样，因为这是那些想要独裁统治和武力统治而不是投票统治的人正在攻击的目标。
That's right. And so to that, can you, I hate for you to make a prediction, but what do you think is the life, we're going to be the lifespan of Travis Kelsey and Taylor Swift? Is there any way that was saying the same thing to the playoffs? Right. I mean, I'm all in. You know, it's, it's all hard not to live. Really. It's a very large man. He's a very large target. There's a lot of ways to make him.
没错。那么对此，你能，我讨厌让你做预测，但你认为特拉维斯·凯尔斯（Travis Kelce）和泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）的寿命，呃不，恋情能维持多久？有没有可能——我们刚刚还在季后赛的时候讨论过同一件事。对。我是说，我全力支持。你知道的，不去看实在很难。真的。他是一个身材魁梧的大个子。他是一个非常显眼的靶子。有很多方法可以让他。
Yeah, you're good to avoid an answer on that one. Now, Rachel, I'm sure that there's a team of incredibly gifted people that you get to work with every day, or maybe not every day now for your show. But yeah, what is your favorite part? I want to ask you to take us through your entire day because I'm sure it's a lot. But is there a favorite part of the day that is potentially completely imploded when there's some breaking news and you got to toss it all out?
好吧，你很擅长避开关于那个问题的回答。现在，蕾切尔，我确信有一支才华横溢的团队每天都在和你一起工作，或者现在可能不是每天都为你的节目工作。但是，是的，你最喜欢哪个部分？我不想让你带我们回顾你的一整天，因为我确信那会有很多内容。但有没有这样一部分工作，当有突发新闻你必须把一切都抛弃时，它可能会完全被打乱？
What's your favorite part of that collaboration? Part of the reason that I left doing five days a week and went to one day a week is that I felt like my thoughts were getting shorter, that I was starting to think and short thoughts without law. I wanted to think book length thoughts instead of tweet length. Lots. And so now that I have this new schedule, I'm spending a lot of time and I'm working on a
你最喜欢这种合作的哪一部分？我之所以把每周工作五天缩减到每周工作一天，部分原因是我觉得我的思想变得越来越碎片化，我开始用短平快的思维去思考，而没有深度。我想思考书本厚度的思想，而不是推特长度的思想。许多思想。所以现在有了这个新日程，我花了很多时间在处理
lot of projects that involve me reading a lot of books. And so, I'm often kind of, I look like I'm going to get smothered by a collapsing pile of books about Nazis at any time of the day. But to have to like dig myself out of my home library where I'm dug into, you know, something going on in the 1920s in Mexico. And then have to jump into like, wait, the bankruptcy court judge said, what about Trump Soho?
许多需要我阅读大量书籍的项目上。所以，我经常处于一种情况——我看起来随时都可能被一堆关于纳粹的书籍的坍塌给埋住。但不得不把自己从家庭图书馆里挖出来，我在那里正埋头研究，比如说，20世纪20年代墨西哥发生的某件事。然后不得不立刻切换到，等等，破产法庭法官刚刚对特朗普苏荷（Trump Soho）项目说了什么？
Can't be a little weird. Yeah, so you must have an incredible team of researchers that can keep you up to date and or answer questions when you have them about where the legal ramifications of XY or Z. I mean, it's probably never ending. Well, MSNBC made a good decision. I mean, in the Trump era, everybody in the news had to become like a jailhouse lawyer. Like we all had to learn. Yeah.
这难道不是很诡异吗？是的，所以你一定有一支了不起的研究员团队，他们能让你随时了解最新情况，或者在你有关于某个法律问题的疑问时为你解答，比如X或Y的法律后果是什么。我的意思是，这可能永远没有尽头。好吧，MSNBC做出了一个正确的决定。我是说，在特朗普时代，新闻界的每个人都必须变成那种“监狱律师”。就像我们都不得不去学习。
Yeah. I mean, the same way that we all became medical experts through the pandemic. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. We all developed, or that's expertise. But the MSMDC did a really good thing and they hired a bunch of lawyers, both as on-air correspondence,
是的。我是说，就像我们在大流行期间都成了医学专家一样。是的。是的。是的。没错。我们都培养了，或者说这就是专业知识。但MSNBC做了一件非常棒的事，他们雇了一群律师，既作为出镜记者，
but also as off-air consultants to help us process and understand and be correct about analyzing. You know, it used to be just Supreme Court decision, you'd have to deal with, or an occasional like true crime thing that captured people's attention.
也作为幕后顾问，来帮助我们处理、理解并正确地进行分析。你知道的，以前只需要处理最高法院的判决，或者是偶尔出现一些引起人们注意的真实犯罪案件。
Now, it's, you know, the president in potentially going to jail in four different jurisdictions, you need to know a lot more, with a lot more specificity. You might enjoy this. This is a little bit of attention. We can always cut it about six months ago.
现在，你知道的，总统可能会在四个不同的司法管辖区入狱，你需要了解更多，并且要有更高的精确度。你可能会喜欢这个。这是一个有点题外话的故事。如果需要的话，我们随时可以剪掉。大约六个月前，
I was in Atlanta with Eli, and we got in a normal argument at breakfast over there at the okay cafe, which is a terrific diet. Xring, you and Eli in an argument is all over the field. Yeah, and our buddy Bob, and we were sitting there, and I said, I made the point that, was Chappy out there? Chappy was, no, Chappy was not there.
我和伊莱在亚特兰大，我们在Oké Cafe吃早餐时为了一件事吵了起来，那是一家很棒的餐厅。天哪，你和伊莱吵架简直无所不包。是的，还有我们的朋友鲍勃，我们坐在那儿，我提出了这样一个观点，查比当时在那里吗？查比不在，不，查比当时不在。
He was at the infield with Greg and Clop. And I brought up the point that ignorance of the law is never a defense. As you might know, Rachel, you know that probably. And it's just not. Eli and I went back and forth. So I ended up calling Jeff, who's, I work with, who's also an attorney.
他和格雷格以及克洛普在内场。我提出了一个观点：不知法不免责。正如你可能知道的，蕾切尔，你可能知道这一点。事实确实如此。我和伊莱争论不来回。所以我最后打电话给杰夫，他和我一起工作，也是一名律师。
He agreed with me. Eli said, well, I don't think he really knows, eh? And Eli's from Halifax. So then we call my dad, who's retired for many years. And my dad said, well, actually, Willie,'s from Halifax. So then we call my dad who's retired for many years. And my dad said, well, actually, will he? Yeah, yeah, right. It's not ever a defense, et cetera. Eli didn't believe me.
他同意我的观点。伊莱说，“嗯，我觉得他其实也不懂吧？”而且伊莱是哈利法克斯人。于是我们又打电话给我爸爸，他已经退休多年了。我爸爸说，“嗯，事实上，威利，”——他也是哈利法克斯人。所以我们打电话给我爸，我爸说：“嗯，事实上，威利……”是的，是的，对吧。不知法永远不能作为辩护理由，诸如此类。伊莱不信我。
So we were able to time Eli went to the bathroom. Bob goes on, what's that cameo? Sure, oh god. And we find out that for $100, we can get Alan Dershowitz to do a cameo. So we put in the message and he said, Hey, everybody, just graduating from law school is kind of an inside joke. Tell everybody Eli about whether or not ignorance is the laws of defense. And Alan Dershowitz does this fucking cameo within 20 minutes that we said to Eli in the job.
于是我们趁伊莱去洗手间的空隙。鲍勃说，那个cameo（名人祝福视频）是怎么回事？当然，哦天哪。我们发现只要100美元就能请到阿兰·德肖维茨（Alan Dershowitz）录制一段cameo。于是我们在信息里写道：“嘿，大家，刚刚从法庭学校毕业，这算是一个内部笑话。请告诉大家，伊莱，不知法到底能不能作为辩护理由。”结果阿兰·德肖维茨在我们对伊莱说完这句话的20分钟内，就录好了这段该死的cameo。
By the way, he did it from his home within 20. We're in, we're still in the argument and he gets an email from Alan Dersuit saying, it's never fucking great is that. So what did Alan say in the cameo? He said, you know, I was just getting a massage. I just, you know, I never took the clothes off. These are close. Well, what a cameo.
顺便说一句，他在自己家里20分钟内就搞定了。我们在，我们还在争论的时候，他就收到了一封来自阿兰·德肖维茨的邮件，上面写着：“这绝对是扯淡，太棒了。”那么阿兰在视频里说了什么？他说：“你知道，我当时正准备做个按摩。我只是，你知道的，我没把衣服脱掉。这些是衣服。”哇，真是个绝妙的cameo。
And any, but he agreed with it. He said it's never, you know, ignorance of the law is never a defense. Whether or not you're wearing your underpants. Whether or not you're wearing your underpants. How fucking great is that? That's the best thing. Anyway, sorry.
而且，不管怎样，他是同意的。他说这永远——你知道，不知法律不成为辩护理由。不管你有没有穿内裤。不管你有没有穿内裤。这他妈有多棒？这是最棒的事。总之，抱歉。
We should use cameo more for inside. Stuff like I know. Settling inside jokes and arguments. We should use cameo more for inside. The stuff like I know. Settling inside jokes and arguments. How good is that? A good idea. I got one once from the guy from Insane Clown Posse. Did you really? That was really good.
我们应该更多地用 cameo 来做内部的事。比如，我懂的。解决内部笑话和争论。我们应该更多地用 cameo 来做内部的事。比如，我懂的。解决内部笑话和争论。这有多好？好主意。我曾经从“疯狂小丑帮”的那家伙那里收到过一个。真的吗？那真的很好。
It was thanking me for having done a thing for a pal. But it was just this magnificent font of like every iteration of the F word. I had ever heard used every other, like every possible way. It was like, it was mech and you did, and you did not have a beef with any of the juggalus, right? That's what their followers are called. I'm pro juggalus.
那是感谢我为朋友做了一件事。但它就像是 F 开头脏话的各种变体的一个宏大喷泉。我听过各种各样的，就像每一种可能的方式。就像是，它是机械的，而且你对那些“客死狂”（Juggalos）没有任何意见，对吧？那是他们的粉丝的称呼。我是支持“客死狂”的。
Is that true? Yeah, that's true. The juggal? Yeah, I'm kidding. Do you know what it means to be anti-juggal-o? That you can't get that, don't say that. Really, don't say it. Rachel, when you're home and your pile of books
真的吗？是的，千真万确。那些“客死狂”？是的，我开玩笑呢。你知道反“客死狂”意味着什么吗？你不能那样，别那么说。真的，别说。瑞秋，当你在家时，你那一堆书
reading a stuffed is, is it something you ensues and chat about? Like, do you guys like, Susan's like, hey, honey, what book did you read today? Or is it something you completely do by yourself? And she does this all by yourself. And then you meet for dinner at the end, and you talk about the day,
在读的那些东西，你们会进行深入了解并聊聊吗？比如，你们会像这样吗，苏珊会说，嘿，亲爱的，你今天读了什么书？还是说这完全是你自己做的事？而她完全由你自己做。然后你们在晚餐时见面，聊聊今天的事，
but you don't talk about your books. Pretty much the latter. Yeah, I mean, what I do, which is a horrible thing, is that we'll be out like in the woods on a dog walk or something, and I'll go, hey, do you want a Nazi story? It's always, no. No, really. This one's burning a hole in my pocket. thing is that we'll be out like in the woods on a dog walk or something and I'll go, hey, do you want a Nazi story? It's always, no.
但你们不聊你们的书。差不多是后者。是的，我的意思是，我做的事情是一件可怕的事，那就是我们会去树林里遛狗什么的，然后我会说，嘿，你想听个纳粹的故事吗？答案总是，不要。不，真的。这个故事在我口袋里憋得难受。事情就是我们会去树林里遛狗什么的，然后我会说，嘿，你想听个纳粹的故事吗？答案总是，不要。
No, really. It's always burning a hole in my pocket. Wait, can I tell you please? Like, she'll occasionally indulge me, but I cannot overstate the importance of having a partner who does not value your work. Yeah. I think it's really important. Jason knows.
不，真的。它总是在我口袋里憋得难受。等等，能让我讲讲吗？拜托？就像，她偶尔会迁就我，但我无法不过分强调拥有一个不看重你工作的伴侣的重要性。是的。我认为这真的很重要。杰森知道。
She likes me, but she doesn't care. Jason's well aware. Jason's well aware. Jason's well aware. Yeah, exactly. My daughters, they don't give it up either. They're like, they could not be less interested. It's very good for you.
她喜欢我，但她不在乎。杰森心知肚明。杰森心知肚明。杰森心知肚明。是的，没错。我的女儿们，她们也不买账。她们的反应是，她们不可能表现得更不感兴趣了。这对你很有好处。
It's very good for you. The other day, the other day I was with Jason, and is one of his daughters, so I absolutely love. And I said, Jason, it's like, wait, what did you say? I'm like, Jason, I texted that to you like a week ago, and he goes, and I never responded. And I go, no. And his daughter turns to's like, wait, what did you say? I'm like, Jason, I texted that to you. Like a week ago and he goes, and I never responded. And I go, no. And his daughter turns to me and she goes,
这对你很有好处。有一天，有一天我和杰森在一起，他其中一个女儿，我是绝对爱她的。我说，杰森，就像是，等等，你说了什么？我说，杰森，我大约一周前给你发过短信，他接着说，而我从来没回复过。我说，不。然后他的女儿转向我，就像是，等等，你说了什么？我说，杰森，我给你发过短信。大约一周前，然后他说，而我从来没回复过。我说，不。然后他的女儿转向我说，
that's okay, never response to my text. See that? Oh, not sure. I'm just, he's the worst. I just, I don't think. You're the fucking worst. The ones that are important get the rest. T times.
没关系，从不回复我的短信。看到了吗？哦，不确定。我只是，他是最糟糕的。我只是，我不认为。你他妈最糟糕了。重要的那些得到了其余的。开球时间。
T times, T times. If you said that, you've got to work well. If you ever wanted to get a response to that, Jason, you just go, how's next Thursday at 10 look for you to tee off and then he'll answer you and then you've got him and then you say the real thing. I like to stay occupied during a strike you know I'm trying to keep the brain fresh. No no Sunday dinner when I was out of town is that it still happened dinner happened when I was. Yeah life does keep going.
开球时间，开球时间。如果你这么说了，你得好好工作。如果你想让杰森回复你，你只要说，下周四十点你觉得开球怎么样，然后他就会回答你，接着你就拿捏住他了，然后你再聊正事。你知道，我喜欢在罢工期间保持忙碌，我正试图让大脑保持清醒。不，不，我不在城里的那个周日晚餐，这还是发生了吗？晚餐在我不在的时候发生了。是的，生活确实在继续。
Fuck man it's shocking. Yeah Rachel we love you. We can't love you enough. Such an honor to meet you. I can't believe I'm so busy. No, you're so cool. Thank you for having me. You guys are really awesome.
操，天哪，太震惊了。是的，瑞秋，我们爱你。我们对你的爱意无以言表。很荣幸能见到你。真不敢相信我这么忙。不，你太酷了。谢谢你邀请我。你们真的很棒。
And I'm very, it makes me, I have to say, just briefly, little earnestness. There's a lot of crappy podcasts that have a lot of listens in the world. And it makes me happy and heartened that you guys are so successful with this because you guys are nice and interesting in kind. And that is not usually what sells in this world
而且我非常——这让我，我必须说，简短地说，带点认真。世上有许多垃圾播客却有着极高的收听量。这让我感到高兴和振奋，你们能取得如此巨大的成功，因为你们人很好、很有趣又善良。而这通常不是这个世界上好卖的东西
and you guys are doing, your success in this world makes me happy. Thank you. Oh, thank you. Thank you, thank you. Yeah, we feel the same about you. You've done so much for so many people and I think you're doing,
而你们正在做的事，你们在这个世界的成功让我感到高兴。谢谢。哦，谢谢。谢谢，谢谢。是的，我们对你也有同感。你为那么多人做了那么多事，我觉得你在做，
I think you're doing a great service to the world. So thank you. Thanks guys. Yeah, rest up. You've got a busy year ahead of you. Thank you for spending a little time with us. Yeah, and one of these days I'm going to stop you in New York and then we're going to have a proper meal.
我觉得你为这个世界做了一件大好事。所以谢谢你们。谢谢你们，伙计们。是的，好好休息吧。你们前方还有忙碌的一年。谢谢你们花时间陪我们。是的，总有一天我要在纽约拦下你，然后我们要去吃一顿正经的饭。
Just to have the van pull over and get it out. A little ether cloth. You just put it right over my nose and throw me in the van. That's how everybody else does it. What? That's hysterical. Enjoy the rest of the day. Thank you Rachel.
只要把面包车停在路边把人弄出来。一块沾有乙醚的布。你把它直接捂在我的鼻子上，然后把我扔进面包车。别人都是这么干的。什么？太搞笑了。祝你们剩下的一天过得愉快。谢谢你，瑞秋。
Thank you so much. Thank you. Bye. Wow, JB. Well, that was, yeah, I don't think my, that's the first time my pit started sweating before we started the podcast. Yeah, I was like nervous too.
非常感谢。谢谢。再见。哇，JB。嗯，那是，是的，我想我的——这是我们开始录播客前腋下第一次开始出汗。是的，我也觉得很紧张。
But you didn't even know who it was. No, when she came on, I was nervous. Oh, yeah. I was like, I'll start shit. That's so fucking smart. It's so scared to ask anything that you're gonna, because I'm gonna sound like a dumb shit. Well, but I mean, that's, I think,
但你甚至不知道那是谁。不，她来的时候，我很紧张。哦，是的。我想，我要开始搞事情了。太他妈聪明了。太害怕问任何问题了，因为你会，因为我会听起来像个蠢货。好吧，但我的意思是，那是，我认为，
you don't need Rachel Maddaw for that, John. Well, we have the title of the podcast to cover all that. You know, we're not claiming to be investigated journalists. Nobody's having us on MSNBC, okay? Yes, sure. But I'm so glad the way that that went, because I knew that, obviously, it's kind of baked in that it's going to be political. And we try not to be overly political on this show.
你不需要瑞秋·马多来做那些，约翰。好吧，我们有播客的标题来涵盖所有这些。你知道，我们并没有声称自己是调查记者。没有人会请我们上 MSNBC，好吗？是的，当然。但我很高兴事情会那样发展，因为我知道，很显然，政治是其中不可或缺的一部分。我们尽量在这个节目中不过于政治化。
But so it was nice to have a conversation with somebody who is so political to have it not be, you know, kind of burn it all down. Well, and also not just political, but also really fucking smart. Yeah, really smart. And also, like as I said in the thing, it's like, it's not left versus right
但能与一个如此具有政治色彩的人进行对话，并且不是那种（你知道的）把一切都付之一炬的谈话，感觉真的很不错。嗯，而且不仅是政治化，还他妈的真的很聪明。是的，真的很聪明。而且，就像我在节目里说的那样，这就像，这不是左派对右派
and right versus left. It's really more about everybody's in total of the country. Yeah, it's just about like, let's cracking it open. People like crack it open and shed light on it and go This is actually not the way this is this is not actually quite fair. Let's look at it and be honest about it That's it. Yeah, that's it. Yeah And she does make the medicine go down real easy too. I just love the way she shapes stories and points of view. And she just, she helps my brain get a little bit calmer
以及右派对左派。这实际上更多是关于每个人都拥有这个国家。是的，这只是关于，让我们把它剖开。人们喜欢把它剖开，让阳光照进来，然后说，这实际上不是这样的，这实际上不太公平。让我们看看它并诚实面对它。就是这样。是的，就是这样。是的，而且她也确实让苦口良药变得容易下咽。我就是喜欢她构建故事和观点的方式。她只是让我的大脑变得更平静了一点
based on the way that she's able to articulate some of the stuff that's going on. And maybe some of the things we might need to watch out for. How much, you watch her every night or when she's on. When she's on, yeah. But I'm watching Nicole Wallace and Chris Hayes. And I don't know.
基于她能够清晰表达正在发生的一些事情的方式。也许还有一些我们需要注意的事情。多少，你每天晚上都看她，还是等她出场时看？她出场的时候，是的。但我在看妮可·华莱士和克里斯·海斯。而且我不知道。
How much more do you think that you could get from it if you had less gummy? I just, what I'm trying to do is gummy to news. I'm trying to, I'm trying to see there. There's a combo there that trying to get right mix. Well, it's the perfect, I'm not able to really comprehend a lot of what I'm listening to or looking at. So it needs to be a ton of information coming.
如果你少吃点软糖，你觉得你能从中获得更多吗？我只是，我试图做到的是“软糖配新闻”。我试图去，我试图看看那里。有一个组合，正在努力找到合适的比例。好吧，这是完美的，我无法真正理解我正在听或看的很多东西。所以它需要有大量的信源涌入。
I is be Jesus. It's not true, listener. He's really taking a run at me. I took one on Sunday. It was delicious and it was amazing. Did you had one? I had one on Sunday with Jay. Not Jason didn't have one when I had one.
我的天哪。这不是真的，听众们。他真的在针对我。我周日吃了一个。它太美味了，太棒了。你吃过吗？我周日和杰伊一起吃了一个。不是杰森，当我吃的时候杰森没吃。
Yeah, right. Yeah, no, I watched. Yeah, he watched me. So you did have, you guys did have dinner on Sunday with Jay, not Jason did now when I had one. Yeah, right. Yeah. No, I watched. Yeah. You watched me. So you did, you, so you guys did have dinner on Sunday without me? Yes. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And we do it again too. Next time you want to go out of town and not be with us. Yeah. Yeah. But you know what? Like, to your point, we'll have a good time here. Here we go. Fuck me. No, nobody, nobody, you know, see you come.
是的，没错。是的，不，我看着呢。所以你确实吃过，你们周日和杰伊一起吃过晚饭，而不是杰森，当我吃的时候。是的，没错。是的。不，我看着呢。是的。你看着我。所以你确实，所以你们周日背着我吃晚饭了？是的。哦，是的。是的。是的。我们还会再这么做的。下次你想出城不和我们在一起的时候。是的。是的。但你知道吗？就像，说到你的点，我们在这里会玩得很开心的。我们走吧。操我。不，没有人，没有人，你知道，看你来。
Nobody knows. Everybody. But you nobody, nobody. You know what I mean? Nobody, nobody. It's like, everybody, everybody. It's like, you left her with. It doesn't matter like. Fuck, it doesn't matter. It doesn't matter where you are left or right. It's like, we all have to get along. We all have to let bygones be. Bye.
没有人知道。每个人。但你没有人，没有人。你知道我的意思吗？没有人，没有人。就像，每个人，每个人。就像，你把她抛在了。这不重要，就像。操，这不重要。无论你身在何处，左派还是右派，这都不重要。就像，我们都必须和睦相处。我们都必须相逢一笑泯恩仇。再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
再见。再见。再见。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisantly handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grandterry. Smart, less.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。SmartLess 是由罗伯·阿姆朱夫、本·巴尔巴科和迈克尔·格兰特里 100% 有机手工制作的。聪明，少。
Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Okay, so if you had a time machine, how far in time would you need to go back to be a dominant basketball player of that year? I need to go to when Bob Coosie was playing. Back in the plumber days. 27 year old Shay would give Bob Coosie the business.
我们的下一集将在满一周后发布，你可以在任何你听播客的地方收听，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客或 Wondry 应用上的 Wondry Plus 提前收听且无广告。好了，如果你有一台时间机器，你需要回到过去多久，才能成为那一年的统治级篮球选手？我需要回到鲍勃·库西打球的时候。回到管道工时代。27 岁的谢伊会给鲍勃·库西好看。
He's not guarding me. Hi, I'm Jason Gutsup's young. And I'm Shay Serrano and we are back. We have a new podcast from Wondering. It's called Six Trophies. Woo! And it's the best. Each week, Shay and I are combing through all of the NBA
他防不住我。嗨，我是杰森·贝特曼。我是谢伊·塞拉诺，我们回来了。我们有一个来自 Wondry 的新播客。它叫《六座奖杯》。呜呼！它是最棒的。每周，我和谢伊都会梳理所有的 NBA
storylines finding the best, most interesting, most compelling ones, and then handing out six pop culture theme trophies for six basketball related activities. Trophies like the Dominic Toretto, I live in my life on quarter mile and a time trophy, which is given to someone who made a short-term decision with no regard for future cons twins. Or the Christopher Nolan a time trophy, which is given to someone who made a short-term decision with no regard for future cons Twents. Or the Christopher and all Intennet trophy,
故事情节，寻找最好、最有趣、最引人入胜的 storylines，然后为六项与篮球相关的活动颁发六座流行文化主题奖杯。像“多米尼克·托雷托，我的人生以四分之一英里为赌注”奖杯这样的奖杯，颁发给那些做出短期决定而完全不考虑未来后果的人。或者“克里斯托弗·诺兰的时间”奖杯，颁发给那些做出短期决定而完全不考虑未来后果的人。或者克里斯托弗和所有互联网奖杯，
which is given to someone who did something that we didn't understand. Catalina Wine Mixer trophy. Ooh, the Lauren Hill you might win some, but you just lost one trophy. Follow six trophies on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. Equalist to six trophies,
颁发给那些做了我们无法理解的事情的人。卡特里娜葡萄酒调酒师奖杯。哦，“劳伦·希尔，你可能会赢一些，但你刚刚输了一个”奖杯。在 Wondry 应用或你获取播客的任何地方关注《六座奖杯》。立即加入 Wondry Plus 即可免费收听《六座奖杯》，
and free right now by joining Wondery Plus. Now, they're joining Wonder E+. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无需广告。现在就加入 Wondry+ 吧。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。